the price of wheat has gone up by 68
this year gas prices have just shattered
their all-time record high there's
reports coming out of california that
gas is over seven dollars a gallon so uh
ouch a lot of people of course are
blaming joe biden and there are reasons
to blame him i absolutely think so
especially with us exporting of oil with
keystone pipeline with just recently in
the past couple of weeks biden shut down
new oil and gas leases for climate
change policy and then many of these
democrat personalities come out and say
it's not biden's fault the gas is too
high it's russia's fault okay well it is
going to be russia's fault a little bit
too because the u.s is still importing
oil from russia and now there is
they say bipartisan support to stop
buying oil from russia and if that's the
case it doesn't make sense considering
the war you can't be buying oil from a
country that you're condemning while
funding or providing weapons to
ukrainians effectively playing both
sides
if we stop importing oil from russia
those prices are going to get really bad
so this should be interesting we have a
lot of war news just because that seems
to be what's happening the interesting
thing i'm seeing about the war right now
is that
russia is recruiting foreign fighters
ukraine is recruiting foreign fighters
it kind of seems strange that they're
acting like this isn't an international
conflict when latvia has voted to allow
their citizens to enter the conflict on
the side of ukraine russia's bringing in
syrians i'm like
okay maybe it's still just mid-tier
regional conflict but nato is now saying
they're approved they're green lighting
fighter jets to be given to ukrainians
so i'm kind of like if nato's giving
them weapons and citizens of nato
countries are going in to help you know
fight in this war at what point do we
just say nato has engaged the conflict i
don't know
we'll talk about all that stuff and
probably a bunch of other stuff too
joining us to discuss that is gothics hi
hello hi guys how's it going thanks for
having me here i love your uh castle oh
appreciate it pretty cool and who are
you uh i ask myself that every day when
i look in the mirror
i am a content creator a twitch streamer
to youtuber i used to do gaming content
and now i just rant about things on the
internet wonderful let's rant about
things together all right
we got sheamus i am seamus coughlin of
freedom tunes i make animated cartoons
we upload a new cartoon every thursday
and we're gonna be uploading one
tomorrow as well because we're getting
real crazy
all right by the way last thursday's
cartoon was incredible thank you so much
what's up everybody ian crossland over
here ian crossland.net talk to you soon
and i'm also here in the corner pushing
buttons i'm in going to enjoy this
conversation because it's a very sharp
young lady and i love her input let's
get going before we get started my
friends head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com to pick up your
bag of ageless multi-collagen 51 off
this is from biotrust and collagen is
what you need for your joint your hair
your skin and your nails and you know we
were just skating a half pipe today and
i got achy old man bones we were skating
at escape park we have to altoona and uh
i didn't even realize that i was trying
to do this trick it's called the nollie
flip nose slide on a skateboard and it i
i skated it was like an hour and a half
of trying this one trick over and over
again i didn't realize how long i was
doing it for but i absolutely got
wrecked i was so sore i could barely
move so i'm grateful that i've got my
angels multi-collagen for my old man
knees go to stronger bones in life and
you can get 51 percent off as well as a
60-day money-back guarantee you get the
healthy aging support of collagen in its
ideal forms hydrolyzed collagen peptides
meaning better and faster digestibility
to support maximum benefits and for
every order today biotrust will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through the partnership with
no kid hungry.org to date biotrust has
provided over 5 million meals to hungry
kids please help biotrust hit their goal
of 6 million meals this year it is
non-gmo and free of artificial colors
flavors preservatives and sweeteners
free of gluten antibiotics and rbgh and
rbst nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth or other collagen supplements
there's no clumping unlike other
supplements you'll get free shipping
with every order free vip live health
and fitness coaching from biotrust's
team of expert nutrition and health
coaches for life with every order and
their free e-report the 14 foods for
amazing skin with every order special
shout out to biotrust because you know
they're one of our consistent sponsors
they've been sponsoring the show for
some time now and i have tremendous
respect for all these companies that are
getting behind the work we do and
helping make it possible so again
stronger bones in life.com but don't
forget head over to timcast.com become a
member to support our work directly and
we will have a members only show coming
up around 11 or so p.m as we publish it
for all of you who are as members and as
a member you're helping keep all of our
journalists employed and they're all
eternally grateful as am i and don't
forget to smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends let's read this first
story from the hill
stocks plunge as rising oil wheat prices
shake market stocks fell sharply monday
as the economic fault of russia's war in
ukraine rattled investors the dow jones
industrial average fell almost 800
points monday to close the loss of 2.4
companies in the finance travel
entertainment retail and construction
industries fell sharply monday as
skyrocketing oil prices raised fears of
an economic slowdown while energy
companies rallied on the prospect of
higher prices that's kind of messed up
but uh yeah us gas prices average hits
new record high the previous being set
in 2008. so uh i saw some people in the
chat they were saying doom cast irl uh
are we just
are we just preaching the apocalypse i
mean we didn't make any of this up yeah
it's not like but these stories i think
it's it is a question of what you choose
to focus on and i think sometimes the
show can get a little bit dark but this
is all true it's valid to talk about it
i don't think it's the apocalypse i i
think it is definitely the economy
crumbling like the federal reserve's
fiat currency system is just coming to
an end or some sort of trans
transmutation
yeah no or a great reset it's not yeah i
don't think it's the apocalypse either
well whether or not it's a great reset
is up to you tim it's good to be aware
though right it's good to be aware of it
yeah i mean i don't know i kind of you
know i feel like when you go on
major news sources
i'm not just the only one talking about
what everyone is talking about you know
when i look at what's what's happening
on twitter when i look when i when i go
to like cultural websites
sure they're talking about other stuff
too but like somehow this stuff still
finds its way into the mix like it's not
just a movie something's happening
politically that involves it and i
wonder if the issue is because we talked
about this before with gamergate
that because you can't write video game
news every single day it's only so many
stories you can write about a new video
game they inject politics into it so it
could be that's why politics has become
so prominent but i kind of feel like i
don't know russia invaded a country and
there's like war happening so
well i think it's possible that maybe
we're just talking about this before
everyone else was i think that we've
been talking about this probably longer
than a lot of these other people when we
started to see the news articles come
out that were kind of in agreement with
what we were saying we were kind of like
oh look at this it's really happening
other people really think this so it's
great to be aware of and i feel like
it's part of keeping people informed
just try to stay positive i guess when
uh i think was alex alex jones for sure
maybe the first time he came in with
michael malus and mike in the second
time and he was like it's klaus schwab
klaus schwab's the guy and i was like i
never heard this name before i was like
what's that who's that and he started
telling us and he told us and now it's
to the point where like jp sears
releases a video four or five days ago
about the great reset cloud schwab
blackrock to the heart of the matter
half a million views and it's like
mainstream now so that's a good sign
yeah lindsay's on it james lindsay just
keeps posting the same paintbrush meme
of klaus schwab saying something stupid
have you seen those yeah
i don't i don't you know look
there's uh some billionaires saying that
world war three is coming i guess we'll
talk about that everybody drink i said
it
drink something healthy i'm wondering if
when you look at life
the price is skyrocketing inflation
there some articles are warning
inflation could hit double digits and
i'm kind of like by what metric because
if we're going by the same calculation
as the 80s inflations in the double
digits
so it kind of feels like if you did want
a great reset a war is a great way to go
about doing it
is it possible that the pandemic wasn't
quite enough for it because it felt like
that was a really strong step toward
that i don't know what he said
i think they're trying to destroy the
economy intentionally and i think
inevitably we're
yeah i would say double digits for
inflation i could definitely see that
happening and i think that uh the
pandemic was probably
something that they were using to start
it and i think a lot of people are
falling off of that bandwagon now so now
war
but the media says you're a conspiracy
theorist for saying that even though
wasn't it didn't klaus schwab write a
book called covet 19 in the great reset
or something yeah these people are out
in the open and that's the thing it's
like they're so
open about what their plans are and
you're still labeled a conspiracy theory
for just literally repeating what
they're saying that's the crazy thing no
exactly
who are they convincing are they like
people just trapped in the matrix who
believe it i guess i there are some
people but at the end of the day it
doesn't really matter whether you
believe it what matters is whether
you're willing to go along with what
they're saying i'm not sure that they're
really interested in true believers so
much as they're interested in you not
saying anything when you do see through
the narrative i think that would be fine
if no one believed them but everyone was
too afraid to say anything man how
conspiratorial should we get i don't
know i mean look
at this channel what is it what's like
what does conspiracy theory even mean
anymore georgia guys
that's pretty there are certain examples
there are certain examples of conspiracy
theories which are like so completely
over the line and insane sounding that
you don't even really need the label
conspiracy theory in order to understand
that they're ridiculous like when people
start talking about flat earth yeah but
then when it comes to things like the
lab league hypothesis
and it turns out that it's true it's
like well then the term conspiracy
theory didn't even fit there right and
so i find the term is almost always used
either a where it doesn't apply or b
isn't needed i like the word conspiracy
like can we just talk about conspiracy
yeah but what happened
conspiracy implies a criminal plot right
yes that's why it's stupid like hollow
earth and flat earth there's not a
conspiracy right there's no cabal of
elites who are like we will make sure
the earth is free
i think their argument is it's the cabal
that convinces us that it's spherical
when it's not i see
they call it what what do they say that
you're a globulist
that's a flat earth
it's gotten so twisted to the point
where when i said there was no
conspiracy between donald trump and
russia i was a conspiracy theorist
yeah when i said that the russian
government was not controlling the
executive branch
i was a conspiracy theorist right isn't
that insane it doesn't mean anything
they want to new york times won a bunch
of awards didn't they for the ukraine
thing for reporting on russiagate
claiming that you know donald trump was
secretly colluding with the russians and
they get they i don't think they said
that explicitly because if they did
there'd be bigger news but they did
investigations into like trump's ties
with like russia and they win awards and
everyone's like oh and they're all
clapping like you're so smart then you
know
the the the mueller report comes out and
it's like
none of that happened you won awards for
doing nothing yeah well
none of them lose the awards right no
walter durrante didn't even lose his uh
pulitzer for covering up the hull
anymore right you know you know what i
said i'm like
someone someone uh the response from a
lot of people because russiagate was
wrong they were like well they still did
good reporting and that's why they won
the awards and i'm like listen what if i
if i hire a guy to mow my lawn and i go
inside and when i come outside he mowed
my neighbor's lawn i'm gonna be like sir
you worked really hard you did a bang-up
job but that's not my grass right so you
expect me to pay you nah
like they did the work they did the
wrong work so i don't know what it is
you want me to say but it's just it's
hilarious when the establishment gives
itself awards that's all i think any
time i see any of these ceremonies i'm
like oh you patented yourself on the
back there what a surprise
yeah but you know what's weird is that
there used to be that we used to have
like a mono culture we used to have one
award you know we would not wait all
these award ceremonies and everyone was
just like turning the tv on and watching
everyone turning the tv tv on and
watching super bowl now it's like you
know i was reading about uh joe biden's
state of the union having like the
lowest ratings of any state union in 30
years and i'm like yeah it's because
people are on the internet you know no
one's watching on tv but more
importantly a million like one point
something million people watch steven
crowder's
version of the state of the union where
he's correcting them right and then we
had like 750k vod views on
us nice drinking
drinking our way through yeah so you
have a lot of people who don't like joe
biden who would rather watch us make fun
of him or correct them and so basically
of all these different pockets of
different cultural cultural spheres of
influence
and then
i don't know culture war chaos in
fighting but what brings us back to the
exact reason why they need to use the
term conspiracy theory so much because
information is more widely accessible
and they can't hide it from you but they
can make you embarrassed to repeat any
of the information that you heard and
that's what that label is for it's right
and weird yeah yeah it's just a
deflection tactic just don't care what's
the uh that's exactly what it is you
have to not care because of what you're
saying is legitimate if what you're
saying is legitimately crazy it doesn't
matter whether you get called a
conspiracy theorist you sound crazy
georgia guidestones i'm not familiar
i've heard a little bit about them i
haven't looked into them too deeply well
you want to say something no i was going
to say you you just made a good point
like i remember back in the day i would
watch like alien shows and you were
conspiracy theory okay cool like you
used your brain to conclude whether or
not something is true or not and you
weren't ridiculed for it but now you
can't even come up with a a a theory for
anything without being
no no this is this is why can i
respond to that really quickly
the reason is because when you're
looking at ancient aliens that's
obviously ridiculous people can look at
that and dismiss it but when you're the
only time they need to censor
misinformation is when there's a chance
some of it's true
yeah i was gonna say how come ancient
aliens on the history channel gets to i
mean seriously it's some of the most
racist racist stuff ever don't think
about it crazy ancient aliens
i love you ancient aliens you're a fun
show but when you have like these white
european professors i know sit down in
front of a camera and say there's no
possible way south american indigenous
could build structures like this it had
to be aliens that's so true i'm like oh
my gosh like we just can't figure it out
i think he's like aliens
well it's like ancient rome that
concrete that could set under water and
they're like well of course
but those people in in south america nah
they couldn't have figured anything out
it had the only logical explanation how
they built things was aliens is that
that's pretty much i'm like i'm like how
is that not very racist
i got some information about conspiracy
theories from wikipedia the term
conspiracy theory is itself the subject
of a conspiracy theory which claims the
term was popularized by the cia in order
to discredit conspiratorial believers
interesting particularly critics of the
warren commission who was like studying
the uh kennedy assassination luke said
that yeah i heard that maybe that he's
who i heard it from the cia seeded the
ideas of conspiracy theorists being a
problem when people were like trying to
figure out what happened to kennedy and
they were like no we just want to kind
of sweep it under the rug they're all
conspiracy theorists ignore them and now
the term is so crazy like you said
unless it's breaking a law it's not
really a conspiracy
is it a conspiracy to believe that
aliens like built the incan temples or
something only if it was against
thinking so
you're right like i'm sorry i just got
that i think that if you would argue
that it was a conspiracy theory because
if you were able to determine that
ancient aliens were involved here
archaeologists could determine that too
when they're covering it up i think
that's the theory like they don't want
to let these people with alternatives
different and so that's why they call it
a conspiracy that's a different
conspiracy though right there's the cons
there's the the the show is literally
talking about could aliens have drawn
what are they called the massacre lines
yeah you know those things nazca is
editors yeah where it's like from the
sky you can see these massive pictures
that are what like hundreds of feet long
so cool but from the ground you can't
see anything i'm like maybe they had hot
air balloons on yeah i i want to make a
point here because you were talking
about the warren report um according to
a gallup poll
the majority of americans disbelieve the
official narrative on the jfk
assassination to this day now i don't
really have a dog in this fight i
haven't looked too deeply into it but
in 1975 it was i think yeah 81 percent
of people
said that they thought that there were
more people involved in the
assassination of jfk than were stated so
it's just interesting that in that case
you have the vast majority of people
disbelieving the official narrative
but
you're crazy if you're with them it's
just everyone else is crazy but the 20
of people who are saying yes i believe
the government they're the ones with
their their heads on straight i find
that a little bit so interesting i keep
saying georgia guidestones because yeah
what it really seems to be if you're
being charitable is that like in the 80s
a bunch of rich people
built these big stones in multiple
languages that can perform a series of
functions like there's like a sundial or
something and like some astrological
like there's like math or something i
don't know and then there's like rules
well they wanted to make sure that any
humans who came after us would have
access to certain basic knowledge
and that's what they're called the guide
stones but one of the rules is that the
population of the planet should never
exceed 500 million that's right i've
heard of this so the conspiracy theory
is that there are powerful global elites
that want to purge what is that 7.6
billion people or something yeah to get
us down to half a million now i don't
know if that's true because it seems
like the guide stones if you're being
charitable were just like the height of
the cold war people were scared there
was going to be nuclear annihilation so
a bunch of rich people were like let's
build these big stones that that do
these things and like if we all die
then the people come after us we'll like
find them and be like oh we'll do that i
guess the crazy thing is to say that
population should never exceed 500
million that's so freakish like what do
you do when you hit 499 million 900.
like you just start welling out the acts
like what what the heck exactly well if
you're in a lead i'm telling you this
you don't commit suicide right other
people have to die right
that's crazy
yeah yeah it's crazy i agree with you
completely it's terrific who built these
things i don't know uh i don't know
turner i think ted turner was involved
in it wasn't it
i don't know i might have yeah you gotta
you better back that up okay sorry ted i
mean we don't do misinformation on this
podcast no something else so they exist
they're a real thing
and i
you know my explanation for why they
were built is i believe like the basic
explanation for why they were built but
then the more conspiratorial idea is
that there are people who want to adhere
to its rules now to prevent any kind of
you know mass extinction event in which
case there are people who think they
want to reduce the population of the
planet and then you get look when you
get the world economic forum you know
some of their some of the individuals
involved with them advocating for
western intervention in ukraine which
many people fear could trigger a nuclear
conflict or a greater conflict you're
like
these great reset people sure do want a
war maybe not all of them i don't know
but enough of them and that's kind of
scary you know so you're going to get a
lot more people who are going to believe
these kinds of conspiracies or who are
going to believe there's some nefarious
agenda and then i'll and then i'll put
it this way
if you go to
any reg actually
i'll start this way there's a meme it
says please do not feed the animals
because they will become dependent
and you know so the meme then shows that
says what's the difference between this
and social programs if you go to a human
talking about deer population
someone who knows likes who lives out in
a rural area and asks them what happens
when the deer population grows too large
they'll say oh it's a disaster this
disease starts spreading they start
decimating local you know plant
populations you get an imbalanced
ecosystem so hunters need to go out and
actually start culling the herd
then asks somebody what happens if
there's too many people on the planet
and they'll say
i don't know well i don't know so this
idea
that humans are comparable to deers here
i would or deer here i would reject
because as the world population has
increased overall poverty globally has
decreased
that's actually my point
no yeah yeah no exactly people are more
capable of providing for themselves in
finding creative solutions to scarcity
than any animal is well the issue with
uh with it's not just deer but any large
population hogs for instance it's not
just decimating the environment which i
think humans do to a certain degree it's
also just the spread of disease and then
you also have the uh was the rat utopia
experiment where you end up with um what
was it called cultures beautiful ones
yeah but it was it was like it wasn't
called culture moral sync that's what
it's called
behavioral systems
yeah behavioral sync is one of the
things that occurs are you familiar with
that never heard of it so there was the
the rat utopia experiment put a bunch of
rats and or mice like nut and or rats or
mice different experiments into a space
with tons of food and water and they
could never have to worry about food or
water
what happened was once they reached a
certain population size they started
behaving in ridiculous ways
they started fighting each other some
only groomed themselves they
like just basically their behavior
started to degrade to the point where
they wiped themselves out
and some of the the mice or rats that
were in the experiment were taken out
and rescued and placed in regular
populations but retained the bad
behaviors that ultimately like destroyed
the previous rat utopia
so there's two ways to look at it if we
are overpopulated i'm saying if we are
some people think we're not
if we are
then we're going to end up with mass
pollution we're going to end up with
serious disease pover not necessarily
poverty but you know issues that will
result in a collapse if we are not
overpopulated
but um we are over abunda in over
abundance there's it's like either we go
the red utopia route where all of a
sudden we have behavioral sync we
destroy ourselves morally ethically and
functionally and then cease to exist
or we overpopulate we destroy our
environment and then choke ourselves to
death in our own on our own farts
maybe that's a very pessimistic way of
looking at things that's a little dark i
think but i'm referring specifically
just i'm not saying those are true to
happen i'm just saying in reference to
the fact there's a major war breaking
out that there's great reset people who
are advocating for expanding the war i'm
just making these points
maybe that's their view or something i
don't think necessarily the world is
overpopulated uh i think the problem
comes when if if it is overpopulated and
people also don't have a goal or
something to actually do which is why
whenever i see this push for like a
government dependency and people just
needing the government to protect them
and save them and do everything for them
that's when i get worried because i'm
like okay you're not actually doing
anything to
keep yourself you know you know what i'm
trying to say like that's
i think you make a really good point
which i'll uh add on to i don't think
we're in the rat utopia yet the rat
utopia will happen the moment all of us
agree the government should do
everything for us
because then you end up with the rats
sitting around where the food and water
was given to them right so long as the
rest of us are striving and have purpose
and drive we're resistant to that
behavioral sync and also the ability to
spread out because the utopia experiment
was all about being in an enclosed space
so if we can get off earth where i think
it's a big deal yes getting off earth
but in the right utopia when there was
space they would still all go only in
one side and densely pack it's like
cities that's like the idea
we could spread out but we don't because
everyone wants to be by everyone else i
was gonna say i think my conclusion this
far based on all the chaos we've seen is
that i don't think that people can live
properly in cities that's been my
conclusion i'm like i don't think that's
healthy for people and maybe that's
based on our talk about uh the rat
utopia experiments but people aren't
meant to live that close together yeah i
went to new york once it was terrible
i lived there once it was terrible
i want to add a caveat i think i hear
what you're saying but i would argue
that people are not meant to live that
close to each other without
accountability so historically people
lived in tribes where in many cases you
were really right on top of one another
right but people knew your face and they
knew your name so if you got out a line
that was going to be corrected very
quickly in cities you're very close to
other people but there there's this
strange anonymity there
i like to think of it this way
when uh it's like it's like the various
states of matter when you live out in a
rural area you you are in like a gaseous
community that means you as an
individual can bounce around and do
crazy stuff freely moving around as you
move into more suburban areas the amount
you can move is less so you're acting
more like a liquid and then when you
live in cities you're all stacked on top
of each other hard compressed and you're
stuck exactly where you're so what i
mean by this is
you we have a sphere of freedom and the
more the closer you get to someone else
the more you're compressing that severe
so for example in
new york they pass crazy laws like you
can't own guns you can't have ammo and
you can't play drums in your house for
instance why because the noise would
bother somebody and they would fight and
they're like no no you can't play loud
music out here in the middle of nowhere
you can shoot guns yeah like you not
only can you have the guns you can shoot
them and be very very noisy and nobody
cares because you have more space that
could also explain why formation
psychosis tends to appear in with what
you consider the liberal environment in
the cities because when you're so
densely packed information passes
through you like a like um
like atomically in a solid you can fire
current through it much faster than
through a gas because it's it's just got
something to move it's not getting
bounced off
that's a really good point basically
if you've got 10 people all smashed next
to each other and then you tap one on
the shoulder and say you know carrots
are healthy the information travels
rapidly down the line because everyone
can conveys it to the other person yeah
whereas i mean we don't even need to use
the physics analogy if you live in a
rural area and someone comes knocks on
your door and says carrots are good for
you you have to get in your car and go
drive to your neighbor's house and let
them know and that's very difficult
relative to yelling out the window hey
jim what carrots are good for you all
right
that's it right no no it's true i mean
yeah ideas travel and evolve more
quickly in a more densely populated
environment for better for worse because
that's true for goodness i think for
words for bad ideas yeah i think
generally for worse because even if you
start with a good idea it can be warped
and twisted into something else and to
be fair i think you could argue that a
bad idea could sort of be twisted into
something better but it's for worse
because bad ideas travel really really
fast and need to be checked
and when something's traveling slowly
you have you have an opportunity for the
truth to shut it down and then catch it
as it's spreading when you're in a city
you have a bad idea it just ripples
right through travels halfway around the
world before the truth can strap on its
boots same in crowds if someone panics
in a crowd the entire crowd starts to
move with that panic that's that's
similar to being in a city and for war i
just watched the sum of all fears do you
guys ever see that movie there's no
fears no oh man you guys can't see it's
good when's it from ben affleck i don't
know 2004 or something ben affleck
morgan freeman uh
some other people and basically what
happens is
there's like some organization is trying
to trigger nuclear war between russia
and the us
and so a bomb goes off in in baltimore
and the u.s is like it had to have been
russia russia's like it wasn't us but
the us doesn't believe us
and then so the russian president is
like keep our defenses on high alert
then the president of the u.s goes you
know the advisor says mr president
russia's just put all their defenses on
high alert and he's like what and he's
like get our fleets ready because he
sees them reacting and then they both
start escalating to the point but then i
guess you know like something happens i
don't want to spoil the movie well i
guess it's from 2004 so i'm going to
spoil it no hold on let me take
ben affleck intervenes and gets a
message sent to the russian president
saying you're being played by terrorists
i know you didn't fire that you didn't
detonate that nuke in baltimore stand
down it's the only way and then russia
agrees and stands down all weapons and
then the u.s says stand down stand down
but they're doing a countdown for a
missile strike or whatever basically my
point is when one side gets scared and
the information is rapid then it's just
escalation so there was like there was a
story i heard once where like two guys
got into a minor fender bender but one
guy was like road raging and really
angry and when he gets out they're both
armed and the guy's all super angry and
he's like yeah you hit me you're rear me
and the the guy who re-rented him was an
accident sees that he's got a gun so he
puts his hand on his hip and says back
up buddy the other guy sees him reaching
for his gun so he grabs his gun the
other guy see him grab his gun he pulls
his gun and then the other guy pulls his
gun and then someone gets shot yep
because they both you know we're in this
heated moment they're like no don't do
it stop no then they both pull their
weapons out so things like that can
happen you know i hope that's not where
we're going with this russia stuff but
the issue i suppose is that
no one's gonna back down no one will
like why why would anyone back down you
know it's it's it's
i i actually you know i think maybe the
west backs down in this one because
we're the morally weaker like maybe not
morally we hear the right word we're the
ideologically weaker faction here well
didn't russia offer terms to ukraine
today yep okay yeah ukraine was like
nope really yeah they said eastern
region the donbass region and crimea are
now russia can't join nato you can't
join nato or any block like the eu or
anything like that it kind of sounds
like ukraine is just gunning for
eu slash nato membership at this point
it seems like they're using this
conflict to push towards being joined
with those groups i don't know that's
just my observation i'm not the foreign
policy expert but they are being
incredibly stubborn i don't know here's
what we'll do
oh instead of uh
what oh this next article sorry oh yeah
instead of instead of saying um
world war iii is coming we'll do this
yahoo yahoo.com says
american express follows visa and
mastercard in exiting russia so now amex
visa mastercard and paypal are all
shutting down services in russia in
response russia is announcing they'll be
partnering with chinese union bank for
the mere card network which does operate
in many countries so we're now seeing a
fraction between between two major
economic blocs and um no war will come
of this
no no hyperpolarization no conflict
everyone's going to come together and
the competition will be healthy for
everybody russia will eventually come
and shake hands to the west and say
we're all richer and better off for it
and that's what happens oh yeah yeah
yeah
but but everybody gets mad when i say
this stuff is escalating into war well i
i yeah they're in denial
i know
i i could have told you that having
these big credit card companies exiting
russia is going to push russia toward
china why wouldn't it like china is very
advanced but hold on but like is it
really going to escalate the conflict
between i don't know if it will but it
will ostracize them from the rest of the
west you know
i think the issue is
if there's no tie between
the dragon bear the bricks economic
block
and the western economic blocks
the chance for conflict is greater
because now there's no there's no
cooperation at all
the cooperation helps it's like listen
listen let's not go to war man like i
got a big company i'm buying that new
super yacht chill out man
russia goes to war they invade
and then it's like
what do you do now
now they start seizing super yachts
all these companies are shutting down in
russia and i think it may be in all in
all seriousness i think a lot of
companies expect the united states to be
involved in a war with russia and that's
why this is happening
i think you might be right because
before the show i was like because this
i was a little bit wound up about this
earlier i was like how is it that these
companies can make this unil unilateral
action against russia it's as if they're
independent companies or countries sorry
treating russia as a foreign enemy but
tim was telling me that it's against the
law to do business with these kinds of
enemies
it's complicated but treason is when you
provide
material aid yeah to an enemy of the
united states so specifically if the
united states was at war with russia
and you then traded weapons to russia
you'd be committing treason unless
you're a multinational corporation then
you have no allegiance i technically
that may be true but if you're operating
in the u.s i think the us is going to be
like particularly brutal yeah like come
on like let's be real if uh someone in
the u.s was actively selling materials
to the taliban the u.s would would have
before
like if we gave them a bunch of weapons
or something no that was obama who did
that yeah well i don't know about the
taliban but isis for sure yeah no yeah
historically when the government does it
they get away with it
henry ford sold vehicles to the nazis
for years before the war yeah leading up
to war and then stopped uh yeah i don't
know the actual when he stopped but i
would imagine see that's i would imagine
yeah during the year that's the thing
i'm looking at i'm like why are all
these companies are they really virtue
signaling or
are they concerned that if war breaks
out it will be difficult for them to
immediately sever ties and they don't
want to be on the hook in any way i
don't think
like right now if the us is like we
hereby declare well it's joe biden so
he'd be like come on man we're declaring
russia come on i don't well actually he
can't do it
congress yeah right right but you know i
don't know he might and then they might
be like no joe stop you can't do that
uh
i don't think they're gonna start
arresting executives from these big
companies because they're operating in
russia they would be like you have one
week to cease all operations but it is
disconcerting because one could
certainly lead to the other
and i'm wondering if these companies
cutting off from russia they're they're
they're they're washing their hands of
this economic you know i'm not going to
like russia's the biggest part of the
economy of the world or anything but
they're certainly cutting themselves off
for a major source of revenue yeah
absolutely i wonder if they're they're
they're worried that war well maybe it's
simple maybe i don't get to overthink it
maybe they just fear war might break out
between us and them and so better safe
than sorry it's very confusing to me
because it to me it looks like our
country is weakened so if we were to
potentially go to war with russia i it
to me it looks like we wouldn't lose
just based on like how
culture's been kind of going in a
certain direction for like the last
couple of years we don't look very
strong
so you're saying we would or wouldn't
lose like i i think we would
well it looks like we would based on how
our way it appears that way i agree with
you i have some i have some feelings
that the american military has some
nasty weaponry prepared yeah yeah i
agree with you i hope you're right is
this a poker game like they're making us
look weak yeah yeah it's forty two yeah
that's right when you are strong you
make your opponent look weak but um i
think the reason the u.s could lose well
i should i don't know if i agree with
you that they would but could because
we're so divided with gas prices
reaching record highs yo we were in
central pa this weekend diesel was like
and gas was like 450. yep crazy
so when you see that
we're already in this hyper-polarized
country where everyone's still
constantly fighting
you've got the establishment pushing
their narrative saying trumpers are evil
and all this stuff
one of the things
that precipitates civil war is rising
cost of food
wheat is up 68 percent that freaked me
out there's this viral tweet where
someone was like this is not oil or a
meme stock this is wheat and it's like
going straight and then spikes which
suggests
demand the the expectation is supply
will not meet demand so buy it you know
they're buying it now expecting the
price to skyrocket causing the price to
skyrocket
that's scary because foods foods already
insanely expensive yep
going yeah in fl and
now get this with russia and the us at
odds and you know look visa and
mastercard so what what happens when we
stop importing fertilizer from russia
which we are a major ex importer of i'm
sorry did i say expert what happens when
we start we stop importing fertilizer
from russia right
food's gone yep so i'm i'm thinking you
know kovid may have been in terms of
food shortages a hiccup compared to what
we see now
food prices through the roof food
shortages and gas shortages and gas
prices and you've got a recipe for
disaster people are going to start
screaming for donald trump because
they're going to say trump did not get
us into any new wars gas prices were low
food was abundant unemployment was low
i'd rather have the president who says
no war and fix america than joe biden
and his international whatever i feel
like trump sailed us into the iceberg
and then biden got on board and took
control
how did trump was just printing they
were just the economy was like the best
it's ever been we just keep just the
debt just keeps going up and up and up
and up and he's
didn't didn't repeal the federal reserve
he had john bolton on the board his
sister got him to bomb syria like it
just just his status quo here's his
daughter status quo
you could say that uh obama did that and
trump this whole time none of them
changed course they all have chance and
none of them have done it the federal
reserve is sinking us listen listen
if you're if you've ever been on a
cruise ship no those things are so
impossible to move so let's say you're
on this cruise ship that's been sailing
this way for 60 years
and you get four years to try and turn
it around and you make some turns and
all of a sudden the economy is doing
better you get your troops out of
afghanistan trump did some stuff also if
he tries to turn the ship they're gonna
they got guns and they're like don't
turn the ship sir right that i agree
with yeah so i do feel like trump did
what he could i do feel like trump in
many ways is kind of a bad dude i think
he's a generous guy you hear the stories
about how he's giving his staff all this
money i've heard stories directly from
people who work at his hotel like he
just gives 100 bills yeah so there's
good things there's bad things about him
i think he's kind of an arrogant dude
but i think he did some good things that
he genuinely wanted to you know help
this country the problem is joe biden
gets right back in and of course
corrects and then we go sailing you know
headfirst into ukraine how is it this is
amazing the clinton global initiative is
coming back have you heard this what
yeah no five year hiatus okay under
donald trump
yeah oh my gosh is that a bad thing i'm
looking at you guys and not shook it
back
it's not
we can talk about the global initiative
or whatever their operation is it's
about that when hillary clinton loses
it goes defunct and then donald trump
comes in joe biden comes back in and now
they're kicking everything back up it's
that when donald trump gets elected no
war in ukraine we had the eastern
separatists we had the 2014 regime
change in ukraine we then had eastern
separatist conflict since then but
vladimir putin did not invade ukraine
during trump's presidency what the
establishment says the left democrat
types is that oh because trump was
deferential to putin and giving him what
he wants and i'm like that's kind of an
extreme way of saying donald trump
avoided a war in europe which um if
we're trying to avoid world war iii
then i don't necessarily see anything
wrong with what trump was doing if it
prevented war you know i'll put it this
way when they say that i'm like so
you're saying that everything we're
seeing now in ukraine could have been
prevented that there was something that
you thought was worth
all of this death and destruction that's
kind of crazy to me because under trump
we didn't have that but as soon as biden
comes in all of a sudden putin's like
it's time to go i think the issue is the
democratic agenda clearly at odds with
russia clearly trying to pressure use
nato influence to pressure russia and
put them in a continually weaker
position antagonizing putin which is
which is bad because it got nuclear
weapons
donald trump wasn't doing that donald
trump often said oh he's a powerful guy
man you gotta watch out because he
understood russia was but still you know
avoiding war um
a good thing
now we're at the point where vladimir
putin not only sees the return of the
democrat agenda but but an extremely
weak president
well it's funny how the playbook has
flipped here because i remember in the
early 2000s it was the democrats who are
constantly being accused of being weak
on terrorism whenever they tried to take
any measure that would prevent warfare
and now because trump got through four
years without starting a new war and
because we didn't end up having
tensions escalate with russia we're told
it's because he was weak by by the same
people who were accused of weakness you
know 15 20 years ago wow
it's kind of crazy to think
that the view who was it was like dave
was it david from i don't want to accuse
the wrong person
but to be like donald trump was was
appeasing putin that's why he didn't
invade and i'm like didn't he
donald trump prevented a war with russia
yeah that's all i'm hearing yeah i'm
like okay that's kind of a good thing
well and we were talking about this the
other day i'm not sure if this is just
uh
a trump quote that we haven't verified
but didn't he say that he threatened
putin
he said if you invade ukraine we will
bomb moscow
again yeah the original story was that
he said to putin if you take ukraine
i'll hit moscow but then trump himself i
guess came out in fact check me on this
one because i saw a story and he was
like i told putin i'd nuke moscow
geez
that's not good i don't i don't i don't
like hearing those stories i mean i hear
you but that's definitely not
appeasement for sure yeah and along
those lines i looked up if uh ted turner
was involved with the georgia
guidestones there's no evidence it's
completely anonymous who did those
things but i don't know why his name's
wrapped around you know talking about
this democratic problem that we have or
this liberal economic order-ish problem
i looked up american express and who
owns it let's do some math so vanguard
blackrock and state street own about
17 of of american express but berkshire
hathaway owns 20 of american express who
owns berkshire hathaway oh 20 of
brookshire hathaway is owned by vanguard
blackrock and state street huh so they
own companies that own
companies that they also own so that's
not sketchy no that's not that seems
perfectly totally normal it's beyond
american democracy it's beyond liberal
and and conservative at this point it's
an economic overthrow it's it's they've
been doing it so subtly but it's so
obvious now yeah
i just don't know who they are
the ceos of these companies maybe look
look it goes beyond it's it's beyond the
front man you do deep dive in where's
the money at where's that what's up the
panama papers oh there you go let's blow
them open yeah let's go wasn't there
like a second release yeah i heard
something just came out recently about
it recently i wasn't the journalist who
uh killed yeah he was investigating it's
like the most dangerous thing a rabbit
hole on earth is but i mean you guys
remember when that one dude who had that
island with little girls on it yeah in
his prison cell remember and then the
guy who was working at them like also
died in his presence remember and then
and then the lady who worked with them
got convicted
of trafficking minors but like to who we
don't know
so like to know what we we we can prove
that you were doing this and then okay
well hold on proving that they were
doing it means you know
that there was an exchange between two
parties so who's that party involved
okay if you're convicting this woman
maxwell
that means
you know that other people were involved
uh-huh you know what man
conspiracy it's consistently i think of
uh dantone from the french revolution
who was eventually executed by his
partner robespierre uh and as he was
being executed up in the court he said
better to have been a poor farmer than
to meddle in the politics of man and i
think this now as we're doing this show
if i start naming names and really going
deep on the panama papers and seeing
that's like putting a target on my face
oh yeah why do we wake up and like ian's
just not here i don't want to be i don't
want to do that but like if i don't
address this stuff how do you how do you
fix earth and help humans you just got
to let them like fry themselves and then
regrow from the ashes i don't want to do
that it's what they think they're doing
one day we all come back on the show and
there's like a guy who looks like ian
but it's not even
i do not work with the world economic
forum
i think maybe culture
culture and business you know is the way
to to try to try and fix earth like
elon's building satellite internet that
that's a good start yeah um culture you
make people laugh with movies that's a
good start didn't they actually reach
out to his uh internet service to they
did yeah they actually did that yeah
quite a bit all right that's yeah they
wanted they wanted starlink to block
russia and he was like nah he said first
speech first amendment absolutist sorry
that wasn't the only thing they did they
also asked tess that they also asked
elon musk to shut down tesla vehicles in
russia and he's like no absolutely not
i'm like if this was any other ceo you
have no guarantee first of all isn't
that a core reason why i don't want to
get an electric car yeah i was like no
i'm out on that one for sure that was
crazy that was like it's just some
social justice warriors on twitter so
it's like a serious but he engages so
much we
we should we should read this story
because this is crazy look at this
elon musk mum on twitterverse please to
deactivate teslas in russia who in their
right mind look at this space ceo elon
musk has been mum on requests from
twitter users to shut down teslas in
russia this as he provides free internet
access to ukraine and free charging for
all electric cars in nearby countries
here's an idea shut down all tesla cars
in russia with a note hi guys you'll get
your cars back when you stop fighting
ukraine one user tweeted another said
time to start time to shut down russian
test laws with a kill switch i know you
can do it so far musk hasn't responded
now the first thing i want to say is
well they do mention elon musk says
in reference to censorship he's been
told by some governments to block
russian news sources we will not do so
unless at gunpoint sorry to be a free
speech absolutist bravo good sir i also
want to point out look some twitter
users tweeting at elon musk does not a
story make exactly but
the sentiment among these pro-war people
is kind of nightmarish these are
torch-wielding pitchfork wielding people
who are like screaming burn the witch
and they do it for everything
like the the video i like to bring up
were the guys chasing the woman on the
around the store because she's not
wearing a mask and he's like is anybody
else mad that we all have to wear masks
and she doesn't like these people are
the kind of people who just want to grab
they're like waiting outside saying oh
let me get a pitchfork let me get a
pitchfork i want to chase people and
scream
the idea that we are not going to war
resulting in them just saying escalate
the pressure and the tension and the
pain is a scary thought perhaps what
we're dealing with in this great culture
war or cold civil war is a kind of yin
yang and we are the people who are kind
of like
we should reduce suffering as much as
possible and they're the kind of people
who are like we should increase as much
as possible
yeah i actually um tweeted i was like
what is going to happen when people
can't afford to drive to work and i had
people responding to me saying they
deserve to suffer you know we should
raise the price of gas or like the price
of gas is much much higher in the uk
that's fine they should raise it higher
people need to buy electric vehicles and
i was like what are you talking about
you're just raising net suffering in the
world for what purpose it's because they
don't have a point of reference it
doesn't actually affect their life so
they're not going to care right and it's
crazy because i always used to talk
about cancer culture and why cancel
culture will ultimately lead to stuff
like this and people don't get it it's
it's literally just wanting to incite
more pain but what is that actually
going to do right make things worse
right yeah but they don't know that
or they do maybe they do they do yeah it
reminds me of a kid who's torturing ants
you know they just revel
it's they're just reveling in the
suffering of others it's really weird
man
that is psychopathic to revel in the
suffering of others and to think that
other people deserve to suffer for not
following your particular ideology is
probably as close to evil as anything
that i can come up with i'll i'll i'll
give you guys something to ponder
so i was thinking about this um
several years ago i think when i was in
i might have been in ukraine or or
something i might have been in ukraine
yes like 2013 2014
and like why people are protesting and i
thought about how they say like the
economy is really bad
and you know we work for a month and
what we average the average income is
like 400 a month or something
and they were like if we join the eu the
economy will be better and everyone will
have you know better access to things
and then i was like what
what would happen
if the cost of water was greater than
the cost of labor
if that ever happened you will get total
revolution instantly total revolution
so
we pay our water bills when you live in
a city right so detroit this is what
kind of got me thinking about it was the
detroit and the flint water stuff
it's the most expensive in the nation i
don't know if it still is but it was at
the time
and uh the reason was this was there was
an act there's an activist i know who's
based in detroit who was working on
fixing the pipes and all this was going
down and he said that it used to be
cheap to get water to your house but the
more people leave michigan
then the more the cost of the water
system is spread out among the remaining
populations interesting so if you have a
million people and it costs a million
dollars a month that's a one dollar per
month if half a million leave your costs
just double the two bucks a month
if you know another you know 250 000
leave now it's four bucks a month it's
actually substantially more than that
but because people are fleeing michigan
the cost of water was going up and up
and up to the point where i guess what
happened was flint switched off of
detroit water into like flint river
water which was nasty and then caused
corrosion or something but i digress the
point is i started thinking about this
and i'm like water costs money to get to
you food costs money if high food prices
result in civil war because people can't
work enough to eat then what happens if
they can't work enough to drink any
water it'll be worse than a revolution
because people will be trying to just
steal water like water the most valuable
thing on the planet for you know for
people what becomes such a double bind
when you can't afford the gas that it
cost to get to work like today uh or i
commute 20 miles each way and at first i
was worried because biden was talking
about putting a tax per mile but now i'm
just concerned about the price of gas
and how it's going to affect everything
long term it's only going to get higher
no over here it's gonna hit four dollars
soon it was 350 earlier um this week and
i was like
thank god that i make ends meet but
normal people who are just scraping by
already
unsustainable and what do you do you
can't even uh earn the money to buy the
food you know what the craziest too the
craziest thing
you could do right now is shut off
electric vehicles
this was the stupidest thing these
people could have tweeted
because right now the refuge is in
electric vehicles you're concerned about
high gas prices they come out and they
say well buy electric
if elon musk has the ability to snap his
fingers and turn my car off and he does
that's kind of scary yeah
i suppose though with a lot of modern
vehicles they could do that to any car
if it's gas powered yeah so you know
what here's what i'm thinking i'm going
to buy a bunch of emergency food i'm
going to then buy a car from like early
1960s no like with no computer
components and anything like that an old
mustang or something oh yeah and just uh
get ready for that solar flare or
whatever we got to grow food i think uh
oh we are big time inside indoor food i
think indoor food growing is the future
and should be localized oh yeah every
human should have we're working with
these this company called eden growth
systems right now and they've got this
nasa technology where you can grow like
zucchini and strawberries inside uh four
of these standing things can support one
human indefinitely
so we're gonna get a 200 gallon aquarium
and we're gonna put bantam chickens in
it they're like little tiny ones and
then we'll have miniature eggs every day
i'm just kidding
i'm getting excited
so
no we are actually getting a big
aquarium for raising babies in because
we have actual babies not human babies
because we have 54 eggs currently
incubating
you know this they just keep making more
of them and you know we decided to turn
more into chickens just let them you
know do their chicken things the cost of
gas going up is causing the cost of food
to go up because it costs more to
transport the food the diesel i'm
wondering if there's a way we can make a
kind of uh uh uh fuel for a vehicle out
of egg
oh my gosh and then we can take all the
eggs we don't need i bet we could
because we want to eat
you know what i mean we should you want
to try to use something that has no
other real application yeah the grass oh
we should look into the water car
stanley meyer's water car he had a he
had an engine in 1996 he patented this
engine that could take him he said in 22
hours 22 gallons of water he could get
from la to new york and then they wanted
to buy his patent they kept offering all
this money they offered him a billion
dollars he refused he had a lunch
meeting one day with a couple of
investors and in the middle of lunch
meeting they poured him some credits he
runs out grabbing his throat and his
brother comes out and he's like they
poisoned me and he died i don't believe
that stuff look this guy up stanley
meyer it is freakish who told that story
i just it's on the internet this video
of him pouring water into the gas tank
and being like showing he goes down the
river and he gets water out of the river
pours it into his tank and turns his
motorcycle yeah but this could so i
don't know much about this is this the
electrolysis vehicle because that's not
that's that's a that's true it's just
the issue is it takes more energy to
perform the electrolysis to get the fuel
out of the
that what i was reading said that he was
getting a net positive energy because
the water was the additive energy no so
you need uh an electrical current to
separate the the the base elements of
the water to utilize the hydrogen right
so that the issue was the water car
worked everyone knows it works but you
need a greater charge externally to
generate the fuel
to generate the electrolysis which which
creates the fuel from the water so it's
not like you just pour water in and
drive you need a battery and it's just a
kind of combustion
well i'm gonna look i'm gonna look more
into this so i can bring a deeper
understanding of stanley meyer's water
car because if we can use water as fuel
that would be revolutionary i think that
um
it may be noble to think of these
revolutionary things man but i think
you've got to obey the laws of
thermodynamics and we shouldn't get into
wishful thinking
the energy you put into it is you're
getting the energy you're putting into
is the water so it's not that you're
getting more energy out you already have
the input and i don't think you've read
enough about what happens if there's a
drought you're right
uh that will exacerbate everything
that's happening on earth right now and
what what happens if people need to
drink water and everyone starts pouring
in their cars and there's a water
shortage and the price of water
skyrockets and that's fighting yeah i
think that's all going to happen
inevitably without it being a fuel i
think there's a lot of people who want
to believe in these magical solutions
they want to be like we don't need
fossil fuels we don't need to drill we
don't need this we can just power our
heating and food with good intentions
you know just put on a put on a special
headband and the whole machine just
turns on with the good intentions of but
one man no it just doesn't work that way
we need energy without energy people die
so when greta tunberg comes out and says
how dare you to everybody and she says
we won't wait until 2030 or 20 not even
2023 we want to shut down now it's like
she annoys me she doesn't know what
she's talking about yeah right i mean
that would kill millions of people but
okay
that's an idea let's not do that moving
on and anybody else in the room have any
any thoughts because that was insane
well in it's fun it's ironic because i
think in the long run them trying to
push for these environmental policies
right now is going to be way worse for
the environment overall even like if
those assuming those policies would
actually be effective because if there
is one thing we have seen historically
and worldwide it's that environmentalism
is a luxury and so if you triple our
economy to the point where it can't
bounce back we are not going to be
environmentalists we're going to be
doing everything that we can to try to
survive
yeah and so joe biden
keeping pipelines closed or trying to
implement whatever other
you know energy independence demolishing
pro climate measure
is just going to make it more impossible
and more difficult for our country to
sustain itself and for our economy to
survive which means in the long run
there's going to be less potential to
actually develop the technologies that
would help improve the environmental
circumstances that they're claiming are
going to be to our detriment we're at
like a launching period right now where
you have to you're going we're creating
the momentum to bounce off the diving
board to dive into a future of energy
off of fossil fuels but in order to get
that momentum we need to use the fossil
fuels fusion
stuff like that i think that that's
being repressed personally because the
people in power are afraid that if an
individual had infinite electricity they
it's not they lose control it's not
infinite and it's not infinite you're
right no no no no no no no
i think
the people who run the energy companies
desperately want fusion to work so they
can control it and own it
and then they are the barons of this
massive energy supply so it's good for
them
they make money
how
i don't think you can if i had like a
fusion generator in my house i really
don't want to derail this into me
dreaming about my fusion generator no
this is powerful companies that invest
in new forms of energy because if they
own that form of energy you're dependent
oh yeah if they have the only fusion
generator but if everyone's got their
own no no if they own the fusion
generators in the process
i mean look
you're you're not going to have a home
fusion generator that's that's that's
ridiculous that's what they want you to
do we have small generation fireplace in
your house
we have small generators you can power
your house with but it's not practical
for the in the long term you get you get
a natural gas or diesel generator for
your house you turn it on sometimes but
you're not going to want to keep
constantly putting fuel in it or
whatever fusion's fantastic generates a
lot of energy but it's not perm it's not
infinite energy comes from somewhere so
you'll you'll have a backup generator
for those who have it but the power
plant will just be a fusion power plant
you'll pay your electric bill and you'll
be dependent upon the system that's what
they want you might be able to get a
cold tabletop fusion generator and then
you just pour deuterium into it which is
uh heavy water water with an added
neutron and then um in a palladium
lattice and then you can bombard it with
electricity and you're talking about
science fiction
that's called cold fusion i don't know
if it's science fiction and the issue is
there's not going to be some dude at his
house who's like let me just pour some
heavy water into this machine and ah now
i can power my house for 100 years well
this is not in the ocean i think it's
like i don't know what percentage it's a
very small percentage of the ocean water
is heavy water it's in nature so you
might just be able to pour water in and
and filter out the heavy water
right but but like you're talking about
a hundred years in the future i'm like
about science fiction i'm grabbing at
straws because it is terrifying to think
that we're hung up on oil still and it's
going to be oil because oil works
because oil is profitable no yeah it
does work it's profitable because it
works because it's probably because they
can control who has it no ian you can't
when there's no wind you've got no wind
power when there's no sun you got no
solar power well then when those windows
are wind generators you have no wind
power either when there's when there's
no yes the issue is
when it comes to wind and solar they
don't work sometimes
fossil fuels work 24 7 so long as we're
supplying the fossil fuels into the
machines and if it's not too cold that's
why it works nuclear power works yes
nuclear power is also reliable but for
some reason
the establishment doesn't want nuclear
power
i don't understand they got to sell you
that oil man
yeah yeah also i'll give you that one
you know we absolutely should be
building more nuclear power plants and
we're not yes
absolutely so they do want to sell us
that oil i suppose the fear is that
if we get off oil too quickly
china or some other country swoops in
and starts taking it plus there's oil
interest potential for war like what's
what's china russia or saudi arabia
going to do if we're all of a sudden
just like
oil no more no more petrodollar
i think i think one of the reasons we're
so adamant on maintaining oil is not
just because it works it's got a high
energy return on energy invested but
it's also because the us uses it uses it
as a control mechanism i was thinking if
john rockefeller were alive today that
he would be really upset with what
people did with his oil this whole oil
world i don't think he intended for it
to become a weird
sociopathic monopoly
he was you mean
government control yeah like he
unleashed the beast of greed of just of
covetousness of this oil all over earth
i don't think that was his intention i
think the issue is you can't ship
nuclear power right you build a nuclear
power plant you put small nuclear
reactors in submarines and stuff and
they can power them
but if you want
to transport energy and sell it and
control the mechanism by which it sold
the petro dollar
oil is a substance that can be moved all
around the planet you get everybody to
buy and sell using us currency the
reserve currency and you own everything
that makes sense and it's liquid too you
can give it up pipelines and stuff
that's right and then you've got
pipelines everywhere and they don't want
to give it up
but if we were to shift the united
states to nuclear or other renewables
then we would lose the ability to point
the weapons at people and be like buy it
with our money or else
interesting so how much oil is in alaska
is there any way that we could be energy
independent by that well we were energy
independent technically under donald
trump we were a net exporter of what
right and then as soon as biden gets in
it's like start importing oil again and
it's funny because they're like biden
didn't do anything and i'm like he ended
oil and gas leases because of the
climate cost that was reported by the ap
right that's just i'm not even going to
say anything else joe biden shut down
oil and gas leases like a month ago yeah
he did he was like oh the car the
climate cost is too high okay well you
know
you made a good point that climate that
like caring about the environment is a
luxury yeah it is
yeah it gets scary man i'm seeing i'm
seeing uh discussion among the experts
that if russian imports are shut down
then gas could be over 200 crude could
be over 200 bucks a barrel and then
we're looking at 750 or eight dollars a
gallon
jeez yeah man yeah that's crazy we're
going to be on like horse and buggy
again i know i know
that's kind of cool though horses are
fun
yeah that's fun no definitely like i
don't know i don't want a car i love my
car but you can hug a horse instead of
mechanics you have to go to a vet yeah
yeah really good time
and it's funny because like when you're
like in the carriage and the horse
you can't do it yeah you can't but if
your horse takes a dump no problem
yeah you put jingle bells on your horse
that's right
you're selling this idea that's when the
horse it's like when it's dark at night
and you hear ding ding ding you know how
fast the horse is running and where how
far away from you it is that's why they
put bells on the horse what would road
rage look like with horses
what did road rage look like horses
like people people with like a saber on
the right side or the guy riding shotgun
with an actual shotgun look i'm not
gonna say it didn't exist but also i
think part of the reason you have road
rage is just because of the anonymity of
being behind the wheel if you're on
horses and you're like looking at the
other guy i think people are a little
bit less tough howdy neighbor we're
going slower yeah yeah you're going
slower yeah but people also had swords
and guns no it's true i'm not like yeah
like i'm saying people people got into
fights and they were angry but i know
what i mean it's a big part of the
reason why there's so much road no i get
what you're saying too that there's a
deterrent there somebody's actually
gonna fire you you're yeah there's the
duel yeah that's crazy people people in
government used to duel yeah that was
literally a thing there's actually a
movie about the last duel did you guys
see that no it wasn't some french guy uh
alexander hamilton and aaron yeah and
apparently what did they say hamilton
didn't really expect to shoot aaron burr
he thought it was going to be a
gentlemanly honor thing and that they
would duel but he would intentionally
miss and they would move on but aaron
brown was like oh kill this guy so why
would she why would you assume that
that's not the same
point a gun at you like it's okay they
won't shoot me bro like
i don't think those things were very
accurate and so they're kind of like
walk 10 paces turn around there's a bang
we go home but the guy got him got him
so you know lost his life and then
apparently the younger generation was
offended by it was like people should
stop dueling and i'm kind of like i
don't know some states still have mutual
combat i think oregon has mutual combat
right interesting let's look that up i
don't know how about we do that for the
next presidential election yeah
i
the children of joe biden and donald
trump are are entitled to enter a ring
and challenge each other only only the
presidential families you know we had a
uh tv host radio personality and donald
trump be president i wouldn't be
surprised if we have two fighters that
fight for the presidency in the next
hundred years i wouldn't be surprised
the way it's going yeah washington and
texas are the only two states that still
allow mutual combat so uh washington
yeah washington oregon this thing about
the last duels from 1386 it's a movie
that just came out last year uh in
medieval france jean de carusje i don't
know how you pronounced that exactly
yeah we were dueling in the u.s
interesting it was like the last legal
duel i think in europe i'm not 100 sure
should dueling be legal yeah what do you
say yes yes
you were just
why
why uh because
judging by social media a lot of people
are
are already
ready and they pretend they're tougher
than they are so i would like to
actually do an experiment just for
science i think we solved all of our
problems yeah yeah to all the great
reset world economic forum people who
want to depopulate bring back dueling
perfect and for all those who don't like
cancel culture let the canceled culture
people duel each other it's win-win yeah
here's the thing just goes outside and
starts fighting our country is so
polarized that like for the first week
when people were talking about bringing
dueling back and be like yeah yeah let's
do it and then when it came time to do
it it would happen for like a week and
then people be like all right like i
really don't want to do this no you'd
get you'd get the right being like guys
this is ridiculous we can't just start
fighting each other and killing each
other and the left would be like you're
a bigot dueling should be allowed as
tradition for various cultures and then
as soon as the right says okay fine we
agree let's start doing they'll be like
well we actually think dueling is wrong
we've evolved on the issue this would
never agree on it it's not allowed this
movie is about uh the last what's called
judiciary duel held in france and then
later 1547 was the last legal duel in
france i guess we're still doing in the
united states i'm just saying i think we
should have actual trial by combat like
at a court it's like you walk in and the
judge is like we have the case of you
know the state versus john smith you
were speeding you're going 30 and if
you're you're going 30 miles over into
45
i would like to fight the officer your
honor
the floor expands into an arena and the
cop is like you know you're like gotta
wrestle
like he takes his wig off and he's like
they're all going right now
cops would be very worried about like
they pull a guy over and he's like six
seven and super ripped and he's like you
have a good day sir yeah
let them go if they did let the
presidents duel for combat for uh
experience would they be able to like
claim like a champion like would biden
be able to bring a champion into fight
for him no wait he's too old to fight
too old to fight you're told to be
president bro there you go thank you
perfect i got a legitimate i got i got
an actual idea here's what we do
international law
we we we we would need some way to
enforce it but the idea would be if a
war were ever to break out
instead the first born children of both
countries world leaders have to fight to
the death
oh my and then the winner wins the war
spicy so you'd have like you know
putin's son would be like crazy ripped
and then zelinski's son or whatever and
if they don't have a son then they have
to fight they themselves i wonder if i'm
i'm kidding obviously with that idea but
i'm wondering if forcing the leaders to
put themselves on the line or their
families would be determined
yeah i was just going to say that even
if it's not a dueling thing just in
terms of if there was a war yeah send
them first
send the first born child see how you
know they would be like i would i would
not like to have this war yeah no they
would still do it and then the military
would ensure that their kid was never on
the front lines no no no no no arena
duel like okay everyone shows up and
there's a big you know ring and they
bring the children of the world leaders
who want to who are going to war
and then uh no here's what it would be
the person declaring war has to send
their son and if no son themselves and
the uh person being challenged can elect
anyone they want so here's what happens
every world leader adopts a kid they
don't care about him
i said first they never see that oh well
it could they could just adopt a kid
before they have any children i said
first born or themselves you'll be like
i'm not gonna have kids until after i
declare my wars
that they then they personally have been
there
and then the person who's who is the the
declare e the person who's getting to
war can choose anybody
so like putin would be like we're going
to war in ukraine and it's like all
right it's you or you're your son
disadvantaged and then zielinski would
just be like i'm gonna find some great
you know mma dude and have him do it
there you go i have a feeling that that
is how it used to be and then they were
like we got to start telling them that
we're gods so they stopped making us go
to war with them we watched them get
treated with royalty we watched troy
this weekend you guys ever see troy no
no
and
it's like uh achilles challenges the
prince to a battle i don't know
basically like he walks up to the gate
by himself and they're at war and he's
like hector and then they come out and
they fight one-on-one with all the
soldiers watching and it's kind of crazy
to think because
i can't imagine that if like a u.s
marine walked up to like a an al-qaeda
base or an isis base and yelled al
baghdadi you challenged me they would
just be like bang yeah
next like that was ridiculous what was
that all about but in these old stories
there was like honor and war and like
you would challenge someone to a fight
in fact in the movie the brother of
agamemnon i think it was
challenges paris the prince of troy to a
duel for his wife or whatever and it's
like all the armies are standing there
watching and i'm like this is ridiculous
did they really do that the stories say
that they did that they would send their
best warrior out and then the other side
would send their best warrior and it was
whoever won would basically decide the
battle so you'd have to throw a bunch of
people's lives away yeah maybe we should
still do that yeah i think ballistics
changed everything there's there's the
art of firing weapons the opening scene
is like
sparta's you know confronting this other
nation and they have this big super
ripped guy who's their champion and
achilles comes out and just runs up and
then like takes a sword one shots him
like in the neck and then he's like ah
and then
then the leader of the enemy you know
the other side says like give this
scepter to a king before he rules our
country and like that's how it was i'm
like man that made things so much easier
i guess so i got you're the boss now you
have become the president of this
country because you killed some dude a
guy who was like our guy and you beat
him it's pros and cons to that because
you could get a really strong dude that
whoops the other guy's butt but then
ends up being an absolute idiot so you
know yeah but now it's just whoever's
the best at gossiping yeah we're like
yes you win you can run the country now
you made him look bad and yourself look
good that's it it's kind of crazy how
things have gotten to this point
it is russia is absolutely terrible at
information war
so it's like
with all the censorship with all the
cutting off
it looks like what we're seeing with um
with china with india with mexico as
countries they're actually scared to get
involved and help rush out because they
it looks like they're like nah russia
has been canceled you know what i mean
wow
yeah isn't that interesting that an
entire country could be cancelled and
one of the things i was thinking about
was who do you think that a tesla
cutting off a tesla would affect most
you think that would affect putin you
really think that would affect the
military would it affect olga who's
trying to take dimitri to the grocery
store and buy groceries for their family
like who do you really think is going to
affect i'm like do you want a civil war
in russia do you want them focus on
themselves yes i guess maybe that's an
approach but i but i think uh you know
what you end up seeing with this is just
the russian people genuinely hating the
rest of the world for doing it right
like why are you attacking me what did i
do putin was right right that's what
they're gonna say well we've we've
already seen those huge protests right
of russians who aren't interested in
going to war with ukraine like these are
the normal people who don't like what
putin is doing and we're punishing them
we're taking away all their
entertainment we're taking away their
ability to pay anything talking about
cutting off their teslas for pete's sake
well you know what man i'll tell you the
one thing the only thing that matters is
that sean penn flees to poland on foot
after calling on america to fight for
ukraine why
like
this is this is this beat the game
because he's another exactly he was very
anti-war wasn't he in the early 2000s
was that he's part of his chick in his
activism i'm just exhausted by this sean
penn i don't know or care about you and
why are you telling us to get involved
in a war with russia which is a nuclear
power this is the stupidest thing ever
like we this this actor guy goes to a
foreign country during a war and then
he's like we gotta go fight for them no
no we don't and you shouldn't have been
there i just
you know i will say this americans are
certainly arrogant that's for sure
and um
yeah maybe most of them
you know in different ways
we have this contingent of the hollywood
establishment elites and the democrat
elites and they're just they're so full
of themselves they're so entitled and
then you also have you know many other
americans and maybe more justified in
arrogance you know in the observation of
american power and might around the
world i was just watching a howard stern
clip of uh what's his name from breaking
bad the guy odenkirk and he was like oh
and after you know before he got
breaking bad it was so hard i was
writing and we were barely making any
money and i had to this big loan and and
stern was like oh that must have been so
hard for you
like he was like you know i'm trying i'm
writing movies and taking these little
acting roles and i'm in debt and and
stern's reaction that he must what
suffering you must have been going
through having to write movies and act
and being dead i'm like what how
detached these people have become for
what real suffering is yep yeah
this um this kind of reminds me of uh
the peaceful protests and how a lot of
people were acting really irrationally
like that mass psychosis where now you
got a bunch of people that are openly
just hating
russians because they're trying to like
shut off cars and stop selling their
products and stuff like that it's like
you're you're demonizing an entire
population of people in the same way
that people were so willing to go smash
businesses and and hurt people that
weren't putting their fists up in the
air just because they thought that they
were actually doing something helpful
well in some instances they actually are
vandalizing russian owned businesses or
companies with the word russia in the
name like this happened in canada it
happened in germany it's insane like
this is the beautiful ones dude this is
yeah
okay so let me go back to the rat utopia
yeah yeah
in the red utopia they put all these
rats in a big box they gave them all the
food and water they wanted and then left
them alone and eventually a group
developed called the beautiful ones in
the behavioral sync these are people who
did nothing but groom themselves
they just groomed themselves and tried
to make themselves more beautiful and
that's the virtue signal that's what
we're seeing now with people like sean
penn look at this tweet from him
myself and two colleagues walked miles
to the polish board after abandoning our
car on the side of the road almost all
of the cars in this photo carry women
and children only most without any sign
of luggage and a car their only
possession of value and here's like they
stay they planned this photo of him
walking
this is
sean penn's
vapid
ego
virtue signal on display his intentions
as i this is my opinion of him is that
he wants his name to matter he wants to
be beautiful and seen by everyone so he
flies himself into a war zone and then
makes it about him and what he's doing
and we must fight what are you doing
there this guy has nothing to do with
this no experience here but he wants
people to see him as
beautiful i'm getting tropic thunder
vibes yeah yeah yeah some of that last
night but this but this is virtue signal
to the to the uh nth degree to the to
the like
you cannot virtue signal more than
flying into a war zone and then being
like we abandoned our cars fleet on foot
because only women and shut up if it was
like why don't you put the damn camera
down and help if it's actually
you know this is a photo shoot to me
this is virtue signaling because the in
the behavioral sink the rats or the mice
whichever because they did both just
wanted to look beautiful
well beautiful to rats is just you know
grooming yourself and then having other
rats look at you
for for a a male
it is it is peacocking it is
making yourself as boisterous and loud
and visible as possible
this to me is the epitome of
self-grooming behavioral sync a guy with
no business in this war
flies in
films himself going there
post social media of like look what i'm
doing and it's just like
we've gotten to the point now where we
have these plastic robot people
they treat all of this like a game like
a tv show
this is the most insane thing
you know it's just like
he just wants people to see him and he
wants to say i went to ukraine during
the war
i talked to the families the u.s must
fight it's like shut up shut your mouth
go home you pathetic loser oh who's that
care what you have to say about this you
have nothing to do with it jane fonda
went to vietnam i think and hung out
with the viet cong is that what it was
man the media launched on her for trying
it was basically like if someone was
went to russia right now and was trying
to like show some humanity about the
russian people jane fonda that in
vietnam but they did not people did not
want that
i think this guy's an actor you know
i've always got the vibe from sean penn
that he really wants to help people and
but and so kind of that's kind of what i
was going through as a kid and i thought
let me look into acting so that i can be
famous and then when i tell people like
good ideas that i have i'll be able to
tell them to more people and i think
that's
i've always thought sean penn was a
pretty ethical guy but when you're an
actor that's all you really know how to
do is act you just talk in front of a
camera that's his job it's what he's
done his whole life i don't i've never
seen any other skills this guy has
yeah i think you might be right and it's
commonly said that americans have main
character syndrome and i commented on
twitter that our main import at this
point is narcissism because npr was
talking about how to maintain your
self-composure when you're reading the
news about people fleeing their homes
and being bombed and stuff and i was
like what kind of narcissism is this it
makes us think that we're the most
important people and ian is right about
sean penn being an actor this picture is
so clearly staged it's kind of
disturbing to think that people are
actually suffering and he is treating it
like a movie yeah many americans are and
they're like oh this crazy stuff
happening the ghost of kiev the snake
island and it's like i wonder how much
of this stuff will be proven to be false
as we go on we're just treating it like
a movie oh who are we going to cast as
zelinski when the movie comes around
it's like jeremy renner for sure no what
is wrong with us though like why we've
been thinking about that sean penn
arrives in ukraine to film documentary
about russian invasion the actor and
director came to tell the world the
truth about russia's invasion of our
country says the office of ukraine's
president
imagine
imagine being as vapid as this guy is
he's bored you know what man yeah
you know what man i'm just i just the
virtue signaling has just reached a
point where it's just vomitus have you
guys seen ukraine on fire the
documentary i have not yet it's an
oliver stone so oliver went in there i
think it was from four years ago he did
this this is four years ago so oliver
stone i mean he was talking about this
stuff way before any kind of physical
conflict erupted basically about the cia
coup in ukraine and the installation of
poroshenko and basically how you uh the
you know
the the un or whatever the heck this
body nato is pushing the borders of
russia pushing right up against the
borders of russia
uh and i have a lot of respect for
oliver stone so you want to talk about
some of the entertainment industry
that's really doing good making
documentaries about this stuff oliver
stone is is at the tip of the spear
maybe this will be end up being really
good i don't know i don't want to shoot
it flies in
meets goes to the president's office to
officially support them and he condemned
russia before even knowing was going on
in the country and that's something like
not even anybody advice would do
you know they would go in and they would
have their assumptions based on stories
they read but they wouldn't be like we
hereby declare that we're we're sending
in journalists to uncover all the lies
about the invasion they'd be like we're
sending a reporter to see what's going
on what's up yeah and that's that's
about it and then you know it was like
the crazy thing is vice as like fast and
loose as it was with a lot of its
journalism took it seriously like uh one
of the one of our reporters i remember i
think glenn beck criticized vice when i
was working there
because i think it was danny gold one of
one of the vice reporters went to israel
went to palestine during um
i think it might have been operation
productive edge and danny also went to
israel you know he went to palestine and
israel and documented what people were
going through and glenn beck i think it
was glenn i'm sorry if i'm getting this
wrong maybe it wasn't glenn but some
conservative pundit criticized him
saying they're only showing what the
what the you know the palestinians are
going through and not the israelis are
going through and we're all confused by
that because we are like vice put out
literally two short docs showing the
palestinian and israeli sides of the
conflict and it wasn't really like
like there was it wasn't pro one side of
the others like here we are here's
what's happening
so that that's the issue i take with
this because certainly you know i've had
my share of parachuting into many
different countries but we would never
go in and just you know valiantly decry
and declare we knew it was going on in
fact when i was in ukraine there was um
british media public like publicly no it
wasn't publicly funded british media it
was one of their news corporations had
put out fake news about a protest that
was actually pro yanukovych i could be
getting this wrong it's been almost 10
years
and it was uh a big rally of ukrainians
came out to support their president and
then some media outlet like lied about
it and said it was it was opposing it or
whatever and we were all confused we
were like what they're all waving
ukrainian flags and supporting their
president but of course the western
narrative was the ukrainians hated
yanukovych and they didn't want the
russian regime they wanted the eu and
all that stuff so you got the same fake
news so when i see like these vapid
hollywood actors who specifically fly
into a country
to tell the world the russians are to
tell the truth about russia's invasion
of our country says the ukraine's uh say
office of ukraine's president and he
meets with the president and it's very
clear he has an agenda i'm like this i
just i can't stand the lies in the
propaganda like there are a lot of
journalists down there right now who are
doing a really good job in telling
people what's going on and it does not
look good for russia and that's all you
need to do you don't need to
you know who's cool trey yinks is cool
who's that fox news
trey he's uh i'm pretty sure he's on the
ground right now in kiev reporter oh
cool oh yeah
yeah he does a good job there you go
cool that's what a reporter does they go
down there and say here's what's
happening right like they're tweeting
like air raid sirens like they're not
posting photos themselves with like at
an angle like carrying their bang i
abandoned my car we have to make it to
the border yeah they're not doing that
they're like wearing bulletproof vests
like i'm reporting here in center in
central kiev right now we're hearing
because there's journalism and then
there's whatever this is the beautiful
ones of universe 25. this is coney 2012
2022 remember that movie coney
man the propaganda campaign that was
crazy
everywhere i didn't know what they were
it was it was colony 2012 you guys
remember you remember that it was uh i
remember that
there was this documentary it was a it
was like a commercial and it was the
stupidest thing ever because it was like
the digital media has allowed us to have
power like more than ever before and we
can come together and it was this big
grandiose narrative how we can all join
forces and fight for the good of
stopping this one guy in an african
nation who's i remember wasn't he
already dead and he like yeah he
apparently wasn't even involved anymore
he was an evil guy had child soldiers or
something but yeah he was i think he was
already dead by the time i don't know if
he was dead but he was like he was
ousted already
happening but my issue was kind of like
they made this documentary that was very
grandiose about like global affairs in
the world and they're like and that's
why we need your help to stop one guy
you've probably never heard of in a
central african nation who's like a bad
guy but
man on our list of bad dudes like albert
dottie was still like you know that was
isis yeah well actually 2012 how
prominent was isis back then they were
fairly prominent right jb then i think
no yeah it was before isis yeah you're
right
that was uh and that was was coney
before after bin laden
after needless to say there were many
bad people other than this one yeah it
was all let's come together it just felt
like world economic forum propaganda
looking back on it i was still in the
obama brain fog what was his plan though
well then the guy who did it like from
the organization was like stripped nude
and started like
jumping up and down and banging on the
pavement while gripping himself if you
know what i mean
wow i remember going on
jason russell the director was that it
yeah i'm gonna look into that that
wasn't a part of the tactic
but i'm wondering here's what i'm
wondering
what if the koni 2012 video was the test
firing of a social media manipulation
tactic or weapon basically yeah can we
weaponize propaganda to direct everyone
to do one thing and they tried it out to
see what would happen because you got to
test weapons
and it was a fifth generation warfare i
was thinking about this actually because
technically
people have the data on society as in
terms of okay what do we need to do what
do we need to put in front of people's
screens in order for them to render this
type of behavior and if you think of
like all of these crazy campaigns and
social media trends over the years like
one comes to mind like that als ice
bucket challenge and stuff just just
that and and doing these different
trends you can sort of
guess where you can lead society in a
particular direction just by socially
engineering stuff like that so
technically they have enough data to
know that they can make people jump just
by doing certain things yeah the russian
propaganda campaign has been going on
since
uh 14 2015 16 when did that turn on
2015. i mean they've all everyone's
always running propaganda campaigns like
every country's got it what i'm actually
wondering is um
you guys have heard of havana syndrome
yeah
no so there are people who have reported
that they'll be you know like working in
some government building and they'll
hear a hum and then all of a sudden
those are getting headaches and they'll
start getting blurry vision and they get
permanent like vision damage
and for a while people were just like oh
it must be some something unrelated and
people are overreacting but then the the
white house got hit by havana syndrome
really so it may be some kind of
directed energy weapon meant to cause
long-term damage to a person because
think about it this way if you're if
you're engaged in a war with a long-term
plan
you could be thinking this person could
probably be a threat cause damage to
them now so they don't last five or ten
years in this industry diminish the
amount of time they have so they're not
a threat to you in the future
that's the kind of crazy stuff we're
seeing but here's what i was thinking
with russia
do you guys really believe that nuclear
weapons are the are the pinnacle of
military might these days not anymore no
way yeah well no i mean weapons of mass
destruction generally speaking but we
can also talk about biological weapons
chemical weapons no no no not even laser
weapons i think if you know what it is
then it's not the pinnacle of weapons
technology oh i hear you i hear you we
didn't know about nukes manhattan
project yeah there was speculation until
they got used right yep so there was a
report that came out where it was like
what could they be building some thought
it was like a death ray like a beam that
would like you know cause damage they
didn't know for sure because all of
these different areas were working on
specific things and then journalists
couldn't put it together
so
if the u.s
or any country has something one of the
arguments put forward is that we would
see the the infrastructure operation
you'd see the trucks bringing certain
materials to certain areas and bringing
them underground you'd know they'd be
building something but you don't know
what they'd be building
so is it cyber is it influence
influential is it psychological
manipulation or is it possible that like
we we even understand the concept of
rods from god that's the giant saddle
it's a satellite holding giant tungsten
rods it drops them and they slam into
the earth they're like more powerful
than nukes
could they have something more powerful
than even that i think because they
wouldn't tell us i think that tiny tiny
micro drones that can fly into people's
ears are pretty dangerous
i'm not i don't know about that i know i
don't either that's the problem but
that's a good idea because it's in your
ear tim that's why you don't know
that's a good point right like i'm so
ready to dismiss the idea of micro
drones flying in your ear and like
killing you or whatever but that's
actually a a good idea we would not know
and we would think it was crazy if like
a cia officer was just like the us
micro drones
here kill you like that we'd be like
shut up not true because we wouldn't
believe it i remember i think it's 2004
i was like they can fly a drone into a
window and hurt someone like it was like
groundbreaking the concept of being able
to literally like i don't know if you
guys remember the black mirror episode
but the way they introduced these tiny
lethal drones was because the bees died
i was like oh well we have bees that are
dying that's so interesting what if we
decide to try to fix this problem with
these little drones that can activate if
your social credit score is low or
something like that and that's what
ended up happening in that episode yeah
that's why it's happening exactly look
at this story oh my gosh the disturbing
story of the heart attack gun invented
by the cia during the cold war
the heart attack gun fired a dart made
of frozen shellfish toxin that would
enter the target's bloodstream and kill
them in mere minutes without leaving a
trace
senator frank church holds aloft the
heart attack gun during a public hearing
i mean think about that a frozen dart
with shellfish toxin that sounds like
caveman technology i mean not really but
it's like based on our standards like
sure you're just poisoning somebody
think about what they could make what if
that like polonium in it or something
more brutal so easily to deliver this
stuff so easy to deliver these kinds of
these kinds of things so there's a scope
on it and they hit you with it you have
a heart attack and it leaves no trace
amazing yep and then what how did that
come out do you know much about this
story yeah because these guys are
testifying in front of congress about it
right they say uh in 1975 more than 30
years of almost unrestricted cia
activity came grinding to a halt before
senator frank church on capitol hill
after the shocking revelations of the
watergate scandal okay so i guess it was
water great the american public had
suddenly gained an intense interest in
the activities of their intelligence
agencies unable to resist the growing
disquiet any longer congress was forced
to peer to the dark corners of the cold
war and some of them held bizarre
secrets
what they found was was the stuff of
paranoid thrillers and hair-raising spy
fiction alike aside from plans to
assassinate national leaders from across
the globe and extensive spying on
american citizens investigators came
across the heart attack gun a macabre
weapon that could cause death in minutes
without leaving a trace this is the
story of what may be one of the most one
of the central intelligence agencies
most chilling gadgets that we know of
yeah there was there was an old
conspiracy where this woman was posting
crazy stuff on facebook
and
people started asking like who was she
and why was she posting this because it
was like seemingly random gibberish it
would be a large paragraph saying
something like i went to the store to
pick up an oatmeal spoon but the dog
came running in with the vanilla when i
saw it i screamed and jumped in the car
and drove to the edge of the cliff where
the surfers were screaming like it was
just nonsense right you were like what
is this and so everyone was trying to
figure out what it was
and i don't know if
it could have just been
fake some people believed that what was
happening was that someone working in
intelligence was using a fake profile to
post messages that someone else could
receive
without anyone making the connection the
message was publicly available hard to
find because it was on a random facebook
profile
and the person only the person who knew
what to look for could read it
others speculated that the woman who was
posting it who was older
was former cia and that she had been
drugged with some kind of psychoactive
you know drug to basically corrupt her
mind so that she could no longer tell
people what she knew like it was someone
who knew secrets was gonna blow the
whistle so they used some kind of drug
to twist her brain so she could no
longer form proper sentences was she c
she was cia is that why that just
conspiracy theory just people were like
they believed they found her name
in like
you know uh a debate database related to
like government workers or something
could all just be fake could have just
been someone having having a laugh but
there was like years of these posts
interesting so it was kind of like i
don't know about that it could just be
some crazy lady who was posting random
gibberish because she was unwell but
it's it's crazy to hear these stories
because while that story may be just
totally irrelevant
when you hear about in the 70s they have
a heart attack gun my question is does
the united states or any other
government have the ability to make you
insane
how hard would it be
to do something to someone's brain to
make it so they can't talk properly
uh
i don't know if this is off the list of
stuff we can talk about but can you talk
about other of other governments what do
you mean so i uh
i like to research a lot about things
happening in like uh with china's
government yeah and
i've seen some documentaries you're
talking about the havana syndrome and
i've seen some documentaries of people
that um oppose their government and what
what happens is that there was like one
family where
the regime was sent after them and they
had these types of devices that would be
in proximity to their houses and it
would cause them to become very confused
it would make them ill so it's like what
you're describing is sounds kind of
similar and then i also saw something
about how they're working on something
to
uh
essentially something to do with like
controlling their people's brains i
don't know how advanced they are how far
off that is but
uh yeah that's a possibility from what
i've been seeing well this brings me to
you of all noah harari talking about
hacking humans this is like one of the
number two number three guys at the
world economic forum yeah and he's he's
blatantly saying it has come to the
point now where we can hack human brains
and it's going to continue to happen but
but you got to understand that at a
rudiment in a rudimentary sense hacking
human brain is just talking to someone
right you know true right like you know
what to say to make them behave a
certain way so you publish commercials
subliminal messaging was like the oldest
version of this in media you know when
they'd flash an image in the middle of a
commercial and you wouldn't even realize
you saw it but then you start thinking
about it dude when i was uh uh when i
was like 20 i was hanging out with my
friends and we were watching i think i
can't remember we might have been
watching like colbert report or
something and it was commercial and it
was dumb and it was just like you know
body armor deodorant we weren't paying
attention and then all of a sudden it
went bam
real quick what and i caught it it said
us army go us army what and then my
friend had tivo and so i was like stop
it go back and there was a split second
where it just showed the us army logo
i don't know what it was straight up
from the simpsons yeah joined the navy
and then i was like dude for like a
second it just played a bramp and showed
that and flickered in and out and it
said go army like it was like i think it
was go army it was like it may have been
an army of one whatever the logo was at
the time huh
so i don't i don't know what that was
but it just like flashed on the screen
and so far be it for me to accuse
anybody of doing that on purpose i don't
know
because something yeah there are weird
mix-ups with like the commercials that
they're playing it could have been it
could have been because we were watching
cable for sure interesting like like one
because it was called yeah that's right
that's comedy central yeah yeah i saw
like uh a porn one time and they were
really in yeah let me tell you about it
there was there was some like over the
the video it was talking like the
russians have invaded it is a
humanitarian crisis just like wait what
i kept repeating it over and over again
recently no this was like four years ago
one of the russians invaded oh i don't
remember the exact propaganda that it
was saying but it was like seeding this
propaganda over and over again over the
video i was like what the heck weird it
was blatant it wasn't quiet it was like
it was subtle though it was very weird
very weird the only way to see it was to
listen to it it was crazy
so there
there are that might be true it's going
to destroy your brain there are a couple
um interesting devices that we know
about
so apparently you can buy flashlights
that will shine specific patterns of
light or colors that make people feel
nauseated easily done yeah yeah and then
there's um
ulf sound generators which is also the
subject of ultra low yeah ultra low
frequency um i i think
this may be conspiracy
territory like well it's not a
conspiracy it's not criminal but uh the
idea is the militaries are working on
technology where and look this up
because this this might be nonsense but
i was reading about ghosts a long time
ago and i want scientific explanations
for the ghost phenomenon i don't care
about someone being like it's the spirit
of someone i'm like out here and so what
i read was that in many of these areas
where people claim there's hauntings
they've also found evidence of ultra low
frequencies coming from maybe
underground or from from terrestrial
movement things like that like
geological activity
and this can have an impact on someone's
body and cause manipulations and
perception or a sense of someone being
there around them or something like that
right and so this idea was weaponized
purportedly again i haven't read there's
like 15 years ago i was writing
something on the internet fake but it
was saying something like they have
taken generators that generate ultra low
frequency sound and it causes people to
feel disoriented confused
uh paranoid and sick
so these kinds of weapons
i i would have to say i believe come on
of course militaries around the world
have been working on ways to
incapacitate people by any means
necessary this is the uh from
militarytimes.com it's called talking
plasma you can find that if you look up
militarytimes.com and talking plasma and
uh instead of beaming a flashlight a
flashing light or shouting over a
loudspeaker to keep people away from
sensitive areas new technology being
developed could allow troops to fire a
laser that can form a plasma ball that
talks to the potential intruder what
what talks to someone with a laser okay
this is military tech yeah this is
militarytimes.com pentagon scientists
are making talking plasma laser balls
four uses non-lethal weapons in 2019.
that's more like it i was going to say
all these weapons stop or will be forced
to fire upon you this is awesome i think
a lot of ufos that we see on radar are
these plasma balls being moved around
really fast just with what were you
saying before it was like three lasers
yeah you triangulate at least at least
three three or more by uh quadrangulate
you know you can and then you you hit a
point in the sky and create a ball of
plasma and then you can move so it's
basically all the lasers are
intersecting yeah creating a single
point where the energy intersects you
can see it yeah
crazy
yeah so maybe they're pointing those
towards people's brains i don't know
if they can make their own things
they're to
one day ian's going to be like
complaining of hearing a humming noise
he's going to be like the panama
the panama pump the panama what was it
i can't remember i wonder what they're
talking about i just i i hear you i mean
all this set aside though i i could
understand them developing these
experimental new technologies to use as
weapons but
they pretty much know how to control
people already you just make them
lazy yeah you just have the ability to
defer gratification
they will do whatever you want but
they've already done it yes but listen
no i mean we're here we've got a couple
of us
there are always going to be some people
in a population who don't fall into it
but if they can if they can
take a
sonar dish or something and point it at
you and click a button and then all of a
sudden you're like no what's happening
yes i love joe biden he's the greatest
president they'd do it
they'd be like all right mission
accomplished i have to go make biden
tunes
you're talking about ways to control
that aren't like um taking away
something like taking away your food or
taking away your money yeah well look as
long as you get people to pursue
pleasure rather than virtue as soon as
they believe that public opinion is on a
specific side of an issue they're going
to go along with it because that's
what's easier for them and they've
habituated themselves towards always
taking the path of least resistance
well then how about we
take the path of the super chats that's
right and uh talk to all you guys so if
you haven't already pack that like
button the chicken city livestream is
now up and we are slowly building and
expanding it so uh i don't even know
what the url is that you can say oh but
you know i'll see if i can find it you
can search chicken city on youtube and
it's one of the first ones that will
come up and it just said 24 7. it's been
streaming for days yeah and it's just
the chickens so we're gonna be adding
more cameras we're gonna be adding the
night vision you can listen to them they
scream all day
you can sometimes hear us talking like
when we're walking around outside and
stuff like that so chicken city is
pretty awesome
and um it's it's rudimentary so a lot of
people are like we need more cameras
like yep we've got multiple cameras now
we just need to get to the point where
we can figure everything the idea was as
always start it up slowly build up from
there so we'll be adding night vision
soon but don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show if you really like it posting
that url wherever you can go to
timcast.com become a member right now
because we're gonna have that
members-only segment coming up for you
at 11 p.m and now let's read your super
chats the top super chat whose name i
can't read that's how youtube does it
says see you guys in the wasteland
post-apocalyptia baby
all right pirate torres or to say pirate
taurus spice up chicken city a bit by
theming it like a brothel with a stage
call it kicking chicken city drums bass
horns and all
right
we have a problem because um
we have uh roberto who's the the the
patriarch he is the we never we didn't
intend to buy a rooster we never bought
a rooster we bought we bought eight
chickens a couple died we adopted
another one and it turns out one of our
chickens was actually a dude
well he promptly started making more
chickens with the other chickens and
then we uh we had a bunch of hatch and
one of them is roberto jr
for a while everything was fine because
i made sure you know i talked to some
some chicken tenders you know chicken
farmers and they said it's fine to have
the young cockerel with his dad
because as long as he grows up with them
they won't they don't like it's not like
you know the movies where they fight to
the death they don't do that but they
will like be territorial so now they're
basically like yelling at each other in
competition one will rock a rubber and
then they won't go around and they just
keep going back and forth because
they're like i'm the boss no i'm the bus
and so we may just separate them or
bring more hens in and we got 54 eggs in
the incubator dude we caught some hot
action of the two roosters fighting over
one of the hens
was it the young one that threw the drop
kick yeah double double junior drop
kicked roberto senior i was hot crazy
chicken city is full of drama man people
don't get it like roberto and roberto
junior it's father and son fighting over
these women you know
you should hire someone to just
commentate just yeah
it's a good idea wonderful is walking in
that room
do a clip for us
just get hire someone to sit there all
day watching and just telling people
what's happening you just you have to
get a bunch of angles and then really
dramatize it with music and have like
testimonials with the chickens in front
of the cameras
all right all right let's read more
that's what we got
all right
david c says i know it was a couple
weeks ago but steven crowder did a video
about wikipedia and how to become an
editor and their bias test you should
check it out interesting
jeff rocha says all government is just
theater on a world stage all governments
are in this thing together and all of us
normal people are just their victims
you know i started thinking about how
conspiratorial you can get and it's like
is russia doing this invasion on purpose
to destroy gas prices so they can get us
off of fuel and be like joe biden's
gonna come out and be like gas prices
are at ten dollars we need we need a
green new deal right now
and then everyone's gonna be like please
please anything to alleviate the
suffering
all because of that dang putin who was
on the world economic forum website up
until a couple weeks ago yeah
or
is that stupid and vladimir putin is a
proud guy who was like don't know don't
care and they're like no putin
they've got to know that nation building
doesn't work at this point so like to
put all these weapons on on nato on the
borders of russia just you i think that
they know it it creates instability so
who's making this call at this point it
can't it can't be government it's got to
be some sort of
some sort of corporate authority
extrajudicial authority col dilock says
what you don't understand tim is that
this is normal in war it's called
soldiers of fortune or better known as
mercenary work this sort of thing has
been around since even before the greek
empire and i believe they're referring
to the foreign soldiers who are fighting
on both sides of the conflict um
the syrians are mercenaries right with
the hessians with the british empire
right they send them out here but um
when you have
nato countries
sending civilians to volunteer to fight
for ukraine
these are these aren't mercenaries they
are people who are choosing to come and
fight for a global
institution
or something
that's the crazy thought that people
aren't simply being like
i'm not part of ukraine leave me out of
it no you have like latvia you have
poland you have the us uk citizens being
like we'll all team up and have this
nato alliance of civilians
volunteering and i'm just kind of like
if you're giving fighter jets money and
weapons and your citizens are fighting i
kind of feel like how is that not war
you know like imagine if you know you're
a country and the neighboring countries
like i didn't declare war on you my
people just are invading your country
granted they're not invading ukraine
they're being welcomed in so it is
different it's like joining the
resistance i guess kind of crazy
glenn says tim if a u.s citizen goes to
fight for the for ukraine they should be
stripped of their u.s citizenship so
they can be used as a pu so they can't
be used as a pow or hostage it's
interesting uh russia has put out a
statement saying any foreign fighter in
ukraine will not be treated as a pow
they'll be treated as criminals because
they are not enemy combatants by
international law they're just random
people shooting at their soldiers
i'm paraphrasing basically what they
were saying
which is crazy
goldilocks says mercenaries were even
used in world war two
and on this is common for wars it's just
the first time our generation has seen
it through since a real war hasn't
happened for 30 plus years though latvia
sanctioning it is unusual right when
and that's what i'm referring to i
understand that russia recruiting syrian
soldiers to fight for them is like
mercenary fighters sort of it is a
little different like it's you know but
uh the sixteen thousand foreign fighters
going to ukraine is weird
all right
oh hell no says it may not be the
apocalypse but all signs point to a hell
of a lot darker future than than the
deniers want to accept don't ever water
down the truth
yeah man that's crazy man i mean they
even said it uh world economic forum
prepare for a angrier world isn't that
what he said uh
yeah interesting i didn't see that you
guys ever watched the movie kingsman yes
no i didn't
the bad guy is played by sam jackson and
he's a tech billionaire who wants to
purge the world because of climate
change bro
right yeah
but he's the bad guy i don't know i got
this article that says that uh
transgender women are stuck in ukraine
because they're not letting men leave
the country and it's male on their
identification well they are male
yeah but you know it that's that's not
to make a comment on any of the trans
issues if the government of ukraine is
saying biologically male or female it is
an example of people kind of dancing
around the united states about their
gender but when it comes down to it and
there's war
men fight and women you know women can
also fight but men fight like men are
minor held the fight maybe doesn't
matter what gender you feel like you are
if you're if you've got the bible
i mean
my view is we talked about like women in
the air force when that whole thing
happened with tucker i was like
if you have a hundred soldiers if you
have a hundred men and a hundred women
and we're no longer well actually i'll
i'll i'm gonna i'm gonna
add something to this thought but if
we're at a point where we have absolute
luxury and feminism
you have a hundred men and a hundred men
and only your men are fighting and i
have 100 men and 100 women and i got 100
men and 50 women fighting i got more
soldiers than you and women can pull
triggers too so maybe they won't be as
effective in certain ways compared to
like what the men are able to like
endure like i'm talking about like
lifting things or climbing things
but i got some female snipers that seem
to get the job done oh they can carry
ammo that's for sure they can they can
provide for the war effort they can do
stuff that being said considering the
birth rate is in rapid decline from any
of these countries they probably would
like to like you know not have their
women die in war yeah you can send your
kids too you don't want to do that
either
well so
this is actually something that was said
to me by a female friend of mine who is
in the army in a non-combat role she
doesn't believe women should be in
combat roles because you have to be able
to carry your fellow soldier if they are
wounded and it's much more difficult for
women to carry men
exactly
but i think they're you know the way i
see it is if you've got 100 men and 50
are support rules and 50 are combat and
i got 100 men all combat and 50 women
support roles i'm better off i got more
fighters than you you know like whatever
your view of it is
but then again with declining birth
rates maybe you might want to not have
women die
yeah women are the ones who have babies
we have one we have one rooster who made
all of these babies yep so technically
12 we ordered because we're trying to
get some genetic diversity but we had
one rooster and he sired himself
44
eggs right now very zeus-like of it can
we rename him zeus
so he's already got i think eight
children genghis khan
he's already got eight kids yeah and
he's got 44 kids incubating
one guy
yeah well that's how it works if we had
10 roosters we'd have no babies you know
oh yeah too much competition
all right sean says thanks for having on
gothics highly recommend your viewers
follow her she's a hard-working woman
that dishes out some of the best content
i've i've seen in the last two years
she's informative humble and at times
extremely funny
at times
here he pays 20 bucks to compliment you
that's your response the comment wasn't
good enough
oh here's another one elizabeth carmela
says gothic she's wicked smart i've
learned so much from watching her such a
beautiful person inside and out love her
style too always looking fresh that
person has to be from rhode island if
they're saying wicked wicked wicked
smack wicked smart yeah
filthy hippie says is it a conspiracy to
not tell people you pooped your pants
when you were five years old
i don't understand it depends on how
much of an effort there is to cover it
up
yeah was it illegal what you did i don't
know yeah
let's grab some more super chats
kenny capps says trump should have
released all the jfk tapes and freed
assange that is correct
that's absolutely correct the ultimate
naruto fanboy says yo there's something
on your mic tim it was a stink bug it
was he has been removed
unfortunately for him
at least stink bugs are goofy they're
kind of funny
and the chickens love eating them i
heard that in china they eat them
because they taste like apples
they smell really bad too scared to try
yeah it's like stim stink bugs i see
them around used to have them at my
house uh when i was younger they're just
they're so stupid they're not
threatening you know like right like
there's other pets like roaches or
spiders they're kind of like creepy and
almost a little sinister looking and the
stink bugs are just stupid like i can't
i can't be upset with them like these
bumbling little idiots yeah
you'll like watch them walk around and
you and you'll like put your finger near
it and it just jumps and kamikazes to
the ground and just falls on its back
okay yeah no they just jump off the
walls and fall though really i really
can't they're really slow and they're
really dumb yeah yeah but when they
release that stink oil yeah yeah yeah
you gotta be gentle
then they release the stink bugs
yeah well when you when you're out here
in the summer and there's like 3 000 of
them
last year was crazy bad it was really
bad yeah there wasn't 50 on my way
because they're spreading all over and
now there's that other bug i forgot what
it's called it's that uh it's another
chinese bug and it like destroys trees
awesome
they have the weird spotted feather not
spotted wings or whatever i can't
remember do you think that's his fifth
dimensional war fifth generational war
the stink bug invasion sending invasive
species that destroy our crops they only
arrived like 20 years ago they weren't
around and it was in pennsylvania where
they landed the stink bug infestation
now they're everywhere do you guys
remember at the beginning of the
pandemic people were getting seeds in
the mail from china yes no and people
were planting them according to them
yeah invasive species people were
randomly getting packaged in the mail
they didn't order and they had seeds and
they'd be like oh i'm going to plant
them and they would the heck idiots
right yeah
wait so what were they yes i don't know
yeah we never heard anything genetically
modified plants that we use
five g waves to
choke out well like kudzu in the deep
south is really bad for them like really
bad i don't know where that came from
probably not china ryan b says there's a
bug on tim's mic
dark matter says that stink bug on tim's
mic is distracting
did you guys watch when i flicked him
off or was the camera no i don't think i
saw it send him on his merry way
tadpole says overpopulation of deer is
partly caused by taking best and
strongest from herd they make up with
quantity the loss of quality maybe we've
lost quality
interesting
scary thought
king tesseract says republicans winning
2022 is the best thing that could happen
to the democrats if conservatives want
to make a stand they shouldn't vote for
republicans not senators reps prez only
vote for a rep
a republican governor willing to call
for a convention of states i see what
you're saying i are you saying that
basically the more democrats are in
control the worse it is for them
they absorb all the blame i could see
that yeah yeah he's probably arguing
we're just going to have a collapse
either way and if republicans are in
charge it's going to look like it was
their fault yeah
cal miller says i like how in two months
we went from possible civil war to world
war three crazy times also here's my
super chat worth two gallons of gas
uh ten bucks um we didn't go from
possible civil war to world war three we
went from possible civil war with world
war three yeah it's like a side dish
yeah so great the main course world war
is getting a sequel civil war is getting
a seat yeah it's all happening at once
and we just keep rebooting everything
yeah exactly the writers of this season
world war two part two is that what this
is world war ii part two global world
war two
two
yeah
[Music]
eddie says get tim what does this get
tim instead of city urban liberal types
i prefer crazy urban neurotic tools no
city urban liberal type as a statement
is not offensive in any way but when you
put it together and you show the first
letter of every word it becomes
offensive that's kind of you know that's
the thing not as defensive as theirs
madison lin says ian we only follow
incan laws in my house you're weird and
that was slander i love you anyways i
love you sir
yeah conspiracy theories
people keep telling me i got a stink bug
because
i made a lot you know what we should do
we should put stink bugs on here on
purpose because we don't have super
chats because of that
we know
cyrus inertial says war is going to
happen it's just a matter of time the
east russia and china and west eu nato
are fundamentally incompatible the only
question is how much damage is done to
the world
a lot
helmsway says gas prices in russia two
dollars a gallon for premium fact check
me is that true someone look that up
right now two dollars a gallon for gas
in russia that'd be nice well
we'll see how things play out how much
it usually costs though
raymond g stanley jr says quote don't
make me stick up for trump and quote lol
that's how that's how it went there's a
really funny comedy sketch by a guy who
was titled stop making me defend trump
and it was like he overhears someone
saying something about trump and he's
like that that's not true that didn't
happen and they're like why are you
defending trump yeah do you support him
no no no that just what you're saying
isn't true and they're like you must be
a trump supporter and he's like ugh
yeah tax prices are really low in russia
right now really it's interesting yeah
well it's because they produce a lot of
gas yeah sure it is
travis says ian rolls a solid 100
tonight keep on brother man i'm gonna
roll i'll let you know what i get
ashton hamlet says y'all should check
out inside job on netflix stupid funny
kind of show about conspiracies in the
deep state thanks for being real and
honest i have seen it it was funny-ish
what'd you get 17.
where's the other one
yeah give me your best all right i got
the 100-sided die let's do it wait
good things coming one is all over the
place it is a
27.
almost a 17 though
yes it was almost 17 17 was one the
other direction lockstep yeah you guys
want to roll
let me roll all right
there he goes a hundred they're
basically looking like this is a weapon
they're both yeah they're like falling
on your eyes
so heavy
that was huge
okay here we go it's all new what do you
guys think it's coming i don't know it's
still going
yeah everyone guess mine's chasing yours
yeah coming back battle awesome
they roll where
let's see let's see and we
have 33 83 nice it looks like an 81 83
plus 17 100. oh there you go something
great good work together we rolled 100
that was good here's a good one wounded
man says
buying a freeze dryer a few years ago to
save our leftovers and extra chicken
eggs seems like a good idea now
to some of our city friends who laughed
at us for getting it calling us crazy
preppers but hey i hope the bugs will be
tasty i mean
a lot of people are chatting up random
numbers so we get refrigeration units
that are like on the wall so they don't
take up the floor space oh interesting
what we should get a lot of they still
occupy lateral space that's okay even if
they're not on the floor not ground
space like put them up high maybe you
can pull it open like that or something
i don't know something i probably exist
we have a gigantic freezer full of meat
and we can't stack them that's the point
and pizzas
and peas we got giordano's very
important yeah i order i like ordering
hot dogs and pizza from chicago okay
it's very expensive i'm gonna eat one of
those ladies import hot dogs
so uh you know we have parties where we
we get hot dogs and pizza flown in from
chicago okay
okay
[Laughter]
what we actually do is portellos and
giordano's and lou malnati's because
chicago hot dogs and pizza are very
famous the portillo's hot dogs man and
then you come with the peppers and
tomatoes and the celery salt and
everybody makes them so good they're
good we're we're going to be grilling
jimmy john's on saturday for my birthday
curling jimmy jones grilling yeah
so we were trying to like like i was
asked what i wanted for my birthday and
i said i would like to order a bunch of
jimmy john's
turn on the grill and then open them
apart no just open them and and grill
them for like 30 seconds so they get
like crisps
yeah well not kind of you're not
pressing them you're just open facing
them so like it melts and then so we're
gonna we're gonna do this okay and uh
for the whole week
nothing but jimmy jones yeah what is it
jimmy jones jimmy johnson yeah what's
that sandwiches sandwich yeah just stay
a sandwich but jimmy johnson's a special
company yeah yeah an american
what am i going to do
yeah no way subway jimmy john's man
quizno's good too the business was
founded by jimmy john hey leo towed i
heard stories that he used to walk in to
like the franchise he has he's like a
credit card that says jimmy john on it
and he can swipe it at any restaurant
like he'll walk into a jimmy john's i
don't know if this is true someone i
know who works there told me it was true
then he walks in he's like i'm jimmy and
then he just like hands him the card and
they swipe it and gives him free food
the history is after high school his dad
gave him the ultimatum join the military
or start a business so he started jimmy
johnson's smart guy i don't know why
that got me man i just the idea of him
walking i'm jimmy yeah anyone walking
anywhere before they make a transaction
and going i'm jimmy
i own this franchise like i own the the
the name what about papa john's
papa
we had we had papa john here and we
and he explained to us like everything
wrong with the pizza no way well because
he was like the way the pizza's got to
be made is specific and so he's like see
right here how the crust is not rising
that means they had a problem with this
and over here the sauce didn't go all
the way and he was like explaining
because he takes his pizza very
seriously and he autographed a pizza box
for us we have kind of an open invite to
go down to his his house and do a pizza
cooking contest i really want to go to
learn if we ever have time
all right samuel bonan says i started
making the npc game you mentioned on
friday still a prototype but adding
features what is the best way to talk
share with you
uh
tweet it at ian there you go you heard
the man yeah what's your what's your ian
crossland on twitter send him a tweet
what was what was the npc game we were
talking about like lemmings with npc
faces yeah that would be such a good
idea yeah
you have to it has to be political
though so it has to be like you make
them campaign and do stuff to like get
to the level you have to like yeah shake
a protest sign
if you can throw a molotov
instead of yeah like so instead of like
one lemming you can do the stop lemming
where he like puts his hands up you make
it so that there's like an antifa
lemming holding a sign and like
protesting and they turn the other way
yeah or something like that you could
make them if they get overworked they
can have you angry i don't know if you
can you only do a limited number of jobs
on a lemming or can you just do infinite
infinitely one they can do one job at a
time
but some of the jobs are permanent so if
you make them a stopper lemming they can
never move again right it's bigger i
think
he'll dig until he hits a chamber and
then he stops so if you need to destroy
something in front of the lemming they
have like the pickaxe one and this one
it would be an antifa with like a
baseball bat and he's vandalizing
bashing his way through dude you could
literally well there's a little dark you
could like you could suicide
the lemmings like there was that's in
the game actually explode them no i know
you you if there's some of them blow
stuff up wow
there's a lot of options in there and
then you can hear me
creepy npcs
they make ropes and they climb up
this game sounds like a lot of fun yeah
sounds great yeah that's a good idea
all right
roberto lara says what a great sales
pitch buy electric cars so when you
think against the narrative yeah switch
activated seriously yeah elon's not
going to be uh saying that any time soon
you know thankfully
uh farve fav
honda had a hydrogen version of the
accord in the early 2000's that was for
sale in california there were only two
to three stations across the whole state
and never got traction featured on
british top gear yeah it was a hydrogen
cell though it wasn't uh it wasn't water
it was a hydrogen cell cars and it was a
big deal i remember but like never took
off
storm viking says sheamus looks like the
ben affleck meme where he's smoking a
sig and just has that look of why me
yeah well you guys are doing a great job
good
i hope i don't have that
i'm very blessed i have a very it's a
good movie
it is a good meme
last night sheamus got back he was
came in late like 2am and i was like who
are the elites i was just like really it
was
like the elites are the people that will
never get in trouble for anything they
do there you go and it was just mind
warping thank you shannon yeah you're
welcome well i it was funny i was um
i was driving out from an area where
i've been staying because i wanted to be
back at the house in the morning and i
actually came very close to hitting a
deer unfortunately didn't
and i told ian about it and he was like
that's great we have this whole
conversation about the elites and yeah
listen to this
objective says in japan this weekend the
sesho seki a large stone that in
mythology seals the tamamo nomae the
evil demon nine-tailed fox split in half
thus releasing the demon bad omen that
does seem like a bad omen
look that up the cubie how do you say
nine-tailed [ __ ] sasho seki how do you
spell that
h o s-e-s-s-h-o-u dash s e k i
it sealed the nine tailed fox you know i
know this is fake news because everybody
knows a nine-tailed fox was sealed
inside of naruto
sorry half of it was the other half was
sealed in the stomach of death but you
know
i don't want to be nitpicking right
wow tikkan says no man is more evil than
the one with the righteous cause
is it true the sec uh seshoseki uh is it
split open yeah i was just reading about
it
yeah why would it be on snopes because
they're fact checking it they are
fascinating yeah they are actually seven
hours ago yeah
i bet it's fake news it's true it is
true it's true yeah what yeah
revelation is out whatever they're
saying about the beast and all that
stuff no this is the true sign this is
it yeah yeah the killing stone is split
yeah
how did it split i don't know just
abruptly just ruptured
wait wait it'd be large 2022 a
photograph was circulated on social
media of a famous rock in japan called
sashioseki or killing stone that
supposedly housed an evil spirit this
picture was often attached to a caption
claiming it was recently found split in
half that the spirit or the nine-tailed
fox had been released oh my gosh that's
true it is true as for the facts while
we have nothing concerning about the the
consistency the existence of the evil
spirit which is after all mythical
entity we can say the killing stone
truly split in half in march 2022. wow
the world is over that's it we're done
whoa we're done um i don't know maybe i
i have read every single
i'm looking for a bright side here
no i don't see it i have read every
single chapter of naruto
from the beginning to the end so i i i
can tell you that nine-tailed fox
it's bad news i know a lot about
whatever that means whatever that is
this is the spirit of the nine-tailed
foxes released i have no idea what king
said
i did read naruto though
i started watching attack on titan
recently because apparently jordan
peterson said you had to
and i'm just kind of like it's cool you
know
it's like a weird show i wonder how many
of the episodes he's seen because i got
i kind of got bored with it after a
while yeah you know once a spectacle
wore off of like the big heads and stuff
the big heads the giants which are crazy
one of my favorite memes was attack on
hill
and it was the king of the hill
characters as the titans and hank hill
had spatulas in the direction
that was really good
i'll tell you what it's so good what
whoa what
all right let's grab some let's grab a
couple more
noel p bone says roberto jr con
i'm not sure that's what roberto junior
is yelling no
let's see
raymond g stanley jr says no jersey mics
down there you're missing you're you're
missing out we have jersey mics they're
good too good they're they're good fire
house subs are really good too so yeah
quizno's really good too yeah all those
sandwiches are good but there's
something about jimmy john's it's very
reg it's very basic it's like what do
you get you get lettuce tomato cheese
roast beef yeah and i'm just like that's
that's kind of all i need firehouse is a
good though yeah like firehouse
okay let's grab a couple more what do we
got here
chris wolney says shout out from loudoun
county from a loudoun county neighbor
stink bugs are not as dumb and clumsy as
cicadas if they end up on their backs
they're done
cicadas really
cicadas are pretty dumb too yeah
when the cicadas came out it was awesome
because the chickens it was like
i feel bad for any chicken that was not
around for the great cicada release you
know because chickens don't live that
long that means the chickens that are
born today are probably never going to
experience the the awesomeness of
cicadas yeah because i'd we'd walk to
the tree tree line with gloves in a jar
and in 20 minutes we'd have 50 cicadas
and we would throw them in the chicken
coop and they would just annihilate them
and i was kind of thinking like amanda
imagine what it's like to be a cicada
and like
you come out of the ground and you're
like after 17 years i'm alive and then a
chicken just rips your head off
or you get picked up and thrown into the
gauntlet with a bunch of like massive
chickens like
and you're like
and they just pack you i think i might
have found a picture of the killing
stone split in half on twitter from
lilly0727k
l-i-l-y that's our line we'll have to
customize yeah yeah i can't confirm or
deny but there's
this picture yeah 77 000 retweets
all right let's just grab a couple more
goyu to sama says for that naruto
reference i got i got money see here's
the thing whenever i shout out an anime
people like super chat so uh i tweeted
something
what did i tweet i can't remember what i
tweeted uh
i tweeted what was it about somebody
attack on titan i can't remember what it
was but everyone was like all of a
sudden now i really like your show and
i'm like aha
mention anime people get happy
okay i can't read your name because a
bunch of symbols vanguard and blackrock
run index funds that buy companies in
proportion to their market size
including companies of companies it's
normal
yeah so that's berkshire hathaway
they're talking about yeah all right
let's just do one more alex
thorium nuclear much safer than legacy
uranium fission designs used for
depleted uranium weapons may be my flat
earth type theory but strange to me why
innovation seems stifled in nuclear
energy yeah that weird it's a lot
there's a lot of weird stuff
a lot of technology seems to be not
happening yeah but let's do this we will
go and record our members only segment
so if you haven't already peck that like
button and check out chicken city on
youtube live right now
literally it is it's live non-stop 24 7.
and um there's no lights because
chickens need to sleep and we we do have
the night vision cameras already
but they're not set up because we have
to just slowly build up to that point so
subscribe to chicken city if you want to
just literally watch a live stream of
chickens but i was thinking it would be
funny
if we used the chicken city feed as our
like timcast.com members chat room
so like when you when you go to
teamcast.com as a member it's just there
will be an additional like next to
everything you watch a chat room and
it's just the same chicken city chat so
some people will randomly be like the
roosters are yelling again and they'll
be like i was talking about what alex
jones was saying
[Laughter]
and then someone might be like there's
very little difference you know they're
both ranting
uh but yeah go to teamcast.com be a
member we're gonna have that member
segment up at 11 pm you can follow the
show at tim cast irl basically
everywhere you can follow me at tim cast
gothics do you want to shout anything
out uh thank you guys for having me on
by the way and you can follow me at
gothicstv pretty much everywhere um and
that's about it cool yeah i'm seamus
cogan i have a youtube channel called
freedom tunes we're going to be
uploading a new cartoon tomorrow and
then another one on thursday so please
go check that out thank you very much
for watching yeah ian crossland uh ian
crossland.net if you want to follow me
on social media really great to see you
and that sheamus seamus last freedom
tunes video was insanely thank you thank
you thank you that was awesome
yeah so if you guys want to watch
chicken city just enter chicken city and
youtube and there's a little button at
the top that says live you click that
and you will be taken to our chicken
city i cannot wait to have the infrared
cameras up or the night vision cameras
up i think those are going up next
stoked really glad we finally got it up
you guys can follow me on twitter and
mines.com at sourpatchlids we will see
you all at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you